You
Sir just what are we facing here?
a relic of the old world
Ready your men captain
We will only get one chance
And remember
When you hear the whispers
Call for help
Do not attack
You hear the whispers
What do you think he was on about?
It's Dorman right?
Yeah
Then Dorman
Shut your damn mouth
Why do I always get stuck with these rookies?
Hey the kids got a mean cleave
Give him a chance
Shaman
A
Mean cleave a captain rookie can't even lift his own
Captain Oren captain
It's here rain send the signal
On my back laid off come on
It's a man
Oh
Ron
Are you here
Oh
On your feet lad sir the captain I do be fine here
What is it
Get the body
Stop
Mortal
It can still be contained
You don't know what you have
Your kind no longer control this world
We cannot destroy your body it's true
But you will watch as we destroy everything you have built
Bind him
Feed grow my child
I'll make sure you can eat your fill
I
Hi I'm Jonathan Rogers game director on path of exile 2
Now path of exile 2 is going into early access in around two weeks on December the 6th
But even though it's early access this isn't just some small taste the game is huge
In this live stream we're going to be introducing everything you can expect
So without further ado let's roll the gameplay trailer
Existence is a thing of beauty precious but impermanent
Life and death are mortal enemies and yet bound to one another
The continuation of life must be protected at all costs
Some have said my methods are brutal
To this I say there can be no salvation without sacrifice
I
We are faced with the end and I will do what I must
Those who obsess with death
Let them soon be acquainted with it
Now as you just saw even in early access path of exile 2 is a big game
It's actually been five years since we announced PoE 2 and over that time we've revealed a lot
But it's been in bits and pieces
It's pretty hard to keep track of it all so today we're going to do a full rundown of all the content that will be available at the start of early access
Classes, character progression systems and for the first time a full overview of the end game
This is going to be a big one so get comfortable
For 20 years Rayclast has been free from any sources of corruption
But the Count of Ogham, tempted by promises of power, intends to harness it once more
The day of the end of the game is the day of the end of the game
The dead are rising, monsters are mutating and madness is spreading
Under the dark influence of corruption the Count doles out sentences of death to any who would question him
And this is where you find yourself at the start of PoE 2
Explore the dark forests of Ogham, traverse the barren plains of the Vesteri Desert
And delve into the jungle ruins of Utsal, an ancient Vaal city
There are challenging monsters, hidden ruins, lost camps and treasures, roaming merchants and of course unique bosses
No two areas are the same
It falls to you to track down the seed of corruption, the source of all this devastation
On the way you'll face fearsome monsters, meet strange characters, forge unlikely bonds and uncover lost civilizations
But first you'll need to pick a class
Now Early Access will initially have six classes available, let's have a look at them
The Monk is a fast and furious melee fighter
He dashes in and out of combat and has mechanics that involve building up and keeping momentum
Like all classes in PoE 2, you'll want to use a wide variety of skills to mix and match different combos
To get new skills you will first need to find skill gems
Using a skill gem will open the gem cutting menu which shows all the active skills available in PoE 2
You can choose an existing skill
The Monk is a fast and furious melee fighter
He dashes in and out of combat and has mechanics that involve building up and keeping momentum
Like all classes in PoE 2, you'll want to use a wide variety of skills to mix and match different combos
Using a skill gem will open the gem cutting menu which shows all the active skills available in PoE 2
You can choose an existing skill gem
The Monk is a fast and furious melee fighter
He dashes in and out of combat and has mechanics that involve building up and keeping momentum
Like all classes in PoE 2, you'll want to use a wide variety of skills available in PoE 2
Using a skill gem will open the gem cutting menu which shows all the active skills available in PoE 2
You can choose an existing skill gem
The Monk is a fast and furious melee fighter
He dashes in and out of combat and has mechanics that involve building up and keeping momentum
Like all classes in PoE 2, you'll want to use a wide variety of skills available in PoE 2
Using a skill gem will open the gem cutting menu which shows all the active skills available in PoE 2
You can choose an existing skill gem
The Monk is a fast and furious melee fighter
He dashes in and out of combat and has mechanics that involve building up and keeping momentum
Like all classes in PoE 2, you'll want to use a wide variety of skills available in PoE 2
Using a skill gem will open the gem cutting menu which shows all the active skills available in PoE 2
You can choose an existing skill gem
The Monk is a fast and furious melee fighter
He dashes in and out of combat and has mechanics that involve building up and keeping momentum
Like all classes in PoE 2, you'll want to use a wide variety of skills available in PoE 2
Using a skill gem will open the gem cutting menu which shows all the active skills available in PoE 2
There are 21 active skills for quarter staves, so this just scratches the surface of the options that you have
By endgame you'll be dashing from pack to pack, spewing where you find yourself at the start of PoE 2
Explore the dark forests of Ogham
Traverse the barren plains of the Vesteri Desert
And delve into the jungle ruins of Utsal, an ancient Vaal city
There are challenging monsters, hidden rooms, lost camps and treasures, roaming merchants, and of course unique bosses
No two areas are the same
It falls to you to track down the seed of corruption, the source of all this devastation
On the way you'll face fearsome monsters, meet strange characters, forge unlikely bonds, and uncover lost civilizations
But first you'll need to pick a class
Now Early Access will initially have six classes available, let's have a look at them
The Monk is a fast and furious melee fighter
He dashes in and out of combat and has mechanics that involve building up and keeping momentum
Like all classes in PoE 2, you'll want to use a wide variety of skills to mix and match different combos
To get new skills you will first need to find skill gems
Using a skill gem will open the gem cutting menu, which shows all the active skills available in PoE 2
You can choose an existing skill to level up, or choose to engrave a new one
Since this is a level 7 skill gem, even if you pick a new skill it will immediately be level 7, so there's no harm in trying out something new
The Monk primarily uses the quarterstaff
There are three skills of martial arts, lightning, ice, and wind
But don't think you have to stick to just one, the best combos are going to involve mixing elements of all three
Let's try killing palm
Like many Monk skills this can be used to quickly take advantage of a specific situation
If there's an enemy on low life, you can use killing palm to dash to them and kill them instantly
This will provide a power charge
Then we can use a different skill to consume that power charge for a much more devastating attack
The Monk also has powerful combo skills
Tempest bell for example is a skill that places a giant resonating bell
Hitting the bell causes it to ring, dealing damage to all enemies around it
You can also do things like freeze or shock the bell, which will add elemental damage to the strikes
The Monk also has a variety of abilities to empower his staff
If an enemy is close to being stunned, you can use staggering palm to punch them down
After that, any attack you do will shoot out wind projectiles
There are 21 active skills for quarterstaffs, so this just scratches the surface of the options that you have
By endgame you'll be dashing from pack to pack, spewing projectiles and obliterating screens of enemies with huge combo attacks
Now if you like a style of melee that's a little slower but hits much harder, then the Warrior is for you
He pounds the ground with big chunky attacks and can shrug off the hits of small enemies with large amounts of armor
Even though the mace slams are slow, you never lose control
Longer attacks can be retargeted as you go, and if you find yourself committed to a long attack, you can dodge roll out of it at any time
Among the skill options for maces you'll find a variety of slams, fire attacks, war cries and shield skills
Here I'm going to slam the ground, rending it apart with lines of fire
Any slam skill will then cause these fissures to erupt with lava
I can even run through them with a skill like Stampede to do huge amounts of damage
The Warrior can also use war cries, which can empower your next skill
Seismic Cry for example will double any slams from your next attack
The Stampede counts as a slam so I can double that for even more craziness
If you want to go a little faster and be a little more defensive, equip a shield
In P.O.E. 2 you can raise your shield at any time to block all damage from the front, even spells
While holding up your shield your stun meter will build as you take damage, so be careful
If it reaches 100% your stance will break and you will be vulnerable
Some enemies also have unblockable attacks which are indicated by this red flash
If you see one of these coming, make sure to dodge out of the way
Using a shield also gives you access to shield skills like Shield Charge
which allows you to charge towards enemies and stun them
While charging you're also blocking the whole time so you have full damage immunity from the front
The Warrior also has access to totems
Some totems have built-in abilities like Shockwave Totem
which can be placed to stun nearby enemies and trigger aftershocks like those from the earthquake
But you can also get Ancestral Warrior Totems which allow you to use any slam skill in your repertoire
This is a meta skill, which means that it's a skill you can put other skills into
I can take a slam like Sunder and socket it into my Ancestral Warrior Totem
Now when I summon him, he'll sit there and slam the monsters from a distance
There are 20 active skills for Maces, so there's a lot more to try out
But by endgame you're going to be dropping hammers from the sky, leaping fearlessly into combat
and separating the very earth you stand on
Time for some ranged attacks
The Ranger is primarily about the bow, but we wanted to make sure that she feels agile as well
In Pier 2 you can shoot while moving
Combined with all the skills the Ranger has that allow you to jump around
you'll have a lot of mobility in combat
Bow skills have a variety of lightning, poison, ice and physical attacks
Lightning attacks bounce around between targets
You can also stick lightning arrows in the ground which explode when hit by the bounces
or electrocute enemies to take them out of combat
Ice attacks later slow and freeze enemies to keep them away from you
Using poison not only can you slowly damage your enemies from afar
but also grow some interesting plants
With 21 bow skills and all the mobility and combo tools the Ranger has
you can take advantage of every situation
By endgame you'll be creating hundreds of arrows
be they falling from the sky, bouncing around between enemies or spraying out of tornadoes
You might have noticed in the bottom left of the screen that the flask slots look a little different
In Pier 2 you have one dedicated life flask slot and one mana flask slot
Flasks gain charges as you kill enemies
and typically allow you to heal 6 or 7 times if they're full
But that's not the only thing you can use charges for
Charms are a new item type that will automatically defend you from various debuffs or damage types
Having trouble with getting frozen?
Equip a thawing charm
When it's fully charged it will make you immune to freeze for 3 seconds if you get frozen
To recharge them just kill more monsters
You can gain more slots for charms by upgrading your belt
The Mercenary wields a crossbow that can be loaded with different ammo types
offering versatility, power and mobility
All classes in Path of Exile 2 can be controlled with WASD
which makes this class play exactly like a shooter
For the crossbow you will find skills that work like shotguns
sniper rifles
assault rifles
and even grenade launchers
But not only that there are a wide variety of more interesting elemental ammos too
It's very fast to switch between ammo types as long as you already have them loaded
which makes the Mercenary able to combo abilities together for devastating effect
Use Glacial Bolt to create walls of ice to separate enemies
then switch to Fragmentation Rounds to explode the ice dealing massive AOE damage
If I come across an armoured enemy I could use Armour-Piercing Rounds to break their armour
and then High Velocity Rounds to take them down
Or perhaps I could fire a Gas Grenade to poison enemies
before detonating the cloud with an Explosive Shot for massive damage
If you want to call in some suppressing fire you can summon Artillery Ballistas
These have a minimum range so you'll want to prepare your position carefully before moving in
There are 22 active skills for crossbows
By endgame you'll be calling Destruction down from the sky
as you litter the battlefield with grenades and pepper your enemies with your automatic shotgun
If you're looking to take a backseat and let your minions do the work
then the witch should be your choice
She can call forth hordes of undead monsters to fight for her
while casting powerful Chaos spells that debilitate her enemies
Occult skills are some of the most varied in the game
with skeletons, noxious spells, specialty minions, curses and sacrificial magic
Before we talk about minions we'll have to talk about a new resource in Path of Exile 2 called Spirit
This is a Spirit Gem which allows you to pick from a range of persistent skills
All classes have a variety of these skills which can add some very interesting effects
like Arctic Armor which does cold damage to enemies that hit you
or Raging Spirits which summon fiery skulls each time you cast a fire spell
For the witch though we'll want to be using our spirit to create permanent minions
These minions will be revived automatically when they die
so you don't have to worry about resummoning them all the time
Here I'm using the skill screen to allocate which minions I would like in my horde
You can see the spirit cost of each one
Skeletal warriors are cheap but weak, useful for tanking damage and distracting enemies
But I want more heavy hitters in my army
so I'm going to unsummon some warriors and instead add skeletal arsonists
Permanent minions come with special active abilities called command skills
You can order these guys to detonate your own minions for even more damage and area of effect
If you want a bigger army you'll need a scepter
This new weapon type is imbued with even more spirit allowing you to summon even more friends
And if you want an even bigger army than that you can take advantage of corpses to summon true hordes of minions
But what can a witch do while her army is at work?
Well she has a range of chaos spells to spread disease amongst your enemies or bone skills to impale them
Or you know, you could curse them to make them weaker so your horde can take them down
There are 25 active occult skills
By the endgame you'll be the leader of a fearsome army of the dead consuming everything in its path
The sorceress bends the elements to her will using them to unleash devastation on her foes
This classic spellcaster weaves a flurry of elemental magic from afar
The elemental skills have everything you might expect and more
Fireballs, icy explosions, lightning, and fireballs
Fireballs, icy explosions, lightning storms, you get the idea
Each spell is unique and has many different ways to build and combo with others, even between different elements
For example, flame wall conjures a burning line that not only damages enemies but also empowers all projectiles that pass through it
If you place a wall and fire lightning sparks through it, they'll gain extra fire damage
It's a good idea to take advantage of the ability to automatically swap weapons when you use certain skills
Having a special staff with bonuses to fire skills and another with bonuses to lightning skills can really power up a combo like this
The sorceress can also take advantage of powerful trigger gems
For example, you could grab the cast and ignite gem and use it with firestorm
As you ignite enemies, a counter will go up in the top left corner
When it's full, a firestorm will automatically be cast to the enemy that was ignited
There are 25 active elemental skills
By endgame, you'll be firing off projectiles left and right as you rain down elemental storms on your foes
Now, those are the characters that will be available at the start of early access
But we will be adding 6 more character classes with just as many skills and options as these
There's a lot more to come
There's one more important thing to mention about skills
Even though we talk about them as belonging to each class, in reality there are no restrictions
You can use all these skills on any class so long as you have the attributes
For example, a poison ranger might want to try out using occult curses to increase her poison damage
Or a monk might want to trigger elemental ice walls to use with his glacial cascade combo
The possibilities for cross-class combos are practically unlimited
We're looking forward to what kind of things you guys might find
Now, Path of Exile is a game known for build customization
And we haven't even scratched the surface of what is possible yet
So let's talk about support gems
Path of Exile 2 has a system of support gems that can be combined with your active skills to dramatically change the way they work
If you find a support gem, then right-clicking it will open up this screen
Here you will find a variety of recommended support gems for each of your skills that you can pick between
For example, this is a multiple projectile support gem and can be used to add multiple projectiles to any skill
Normally when you fire a grenade, it will look like this
But if we add multiple projectiles, then you get three of them
Once you have the gem, you can also freely move it between any of the skills on your character
If you want to have a multi-shot sniper rifle instead, then simply move the gem over to your high-velocity round skill
Generally speaking, if it sounds like a support gem should work with a skill, then it will work, so it's a good idea to experiment
Note that you can only have one of each support gem on your character
Note that you can only have one of each support gem on your character, so you'll want to think carefully about which supports can be used best with each skill for maximum damage
Now, if you want to stick to the recommendations, you should have a perfectly good time
But if you want to experiment a bit more, then uncheck that recommended button and you can see the full list of supports that will work with your skill
There are hundreds of support gems to choose from, and even we don't know the results of all the possible ways these can interact
Each skill can have up to five supports socketed into it, and if you're clever, you can come up with some pretty interesting ideas
Now, all of this is just scratching the surface
You can make frost vortexes, break people's armor, make minions explode, make skills repeat
Make enemies set each other on fire, cull enemies, or pin them to the ground
Supports let you drastically change the behavior of your skills and create your own unique build, or at least follow someone's OP build guide
So, speaking of builds, let's talk about one of the most iconic Path of Exile systems, the passive skill tree
Yes, it's huge. There are over 1,500 nodes on there
Now, a lot of people open the tree and can get a little intimidated at first, but try not to be scared
There are lots of options, but at its core, it's pretty simple
Each level, you get one point to put into the tree
Each class starts at a different location, but they all share the same tree
Around your section of the tree, you'll find relevant bonuses for your character
You should be safe in the knowledge that there aren't many wrong choices here
Almost all the starting nodes will be useful for your character in some way
But if you do happen to make a choice you regret, you'll be able to re-spec any nodes you've taken by spending a little bit of gold
Now, the tree is generally divided up into clusters which have similar themes
In each cluster, you'll find small nodes that give simple bonuses like increased damage, but the real power comes from notables
Notables normally have much more interesting bonuses, and they tend to care a lot more about how your build works and what skills you're using
For example, in the mercenary area of the tree, this one gives a 25% chance for crossbow skills to not consume a bolt
And here's one that gives grenades a chance to blow up a second time
This one gives a chance for projectiles to rebound off terrain, as well as giving you some pierce chance to make that more likely
Note that even though this is in the mercenary section, this would work with projectiles from all classes, so there are often reasons to go to different areas of the tree
In order to get between these clusters, you will generally have to allocate nodes in the attribute highways
Attribute nodes allow you to pick which attribute you would like to use, so it's very easy to get points for any attribute that your gear might need
You can change which attribute these nodes give you for half price at the respec vendor
In addition to notables, you will also find even larger passives called keystones
Keystones have both an upside and a downside, and often require changing your entire build to design around them
A great example is Giant's Blood, which allows you to wield two-hand weapons in a single hand, but doubles the attribute requirements of them
You can use a two-hand mace with a shield, or even dual wield them
Or how about Mind Over Matter, which makes all damage go to your mana pool first before your life pool, but you lose 50% of your mana regen
Skills like these can be tough to build around, but if you're up for the challenge, they can be very rewarding
As we showed you earlier on the Sorceress, you can swap between weapon sets on the fly as you use certain skills
One of the new features in Path of Exile 2's passive tree is that you can choose to have your passive tree change as you switch between weapon sets to take advantage of specific bonuses on the tree
For the Sorceress, you might want to change between fire and lightning specialization
Or you could switch between one-hand and a two-hand setup in order to be able to block boss attacks while following up with heavy hits from your bigger mace
Or perhaps you could have a full curse setup on your witch to debuff enemies before switching to a Chaos Degen build for maximum damage
If you want to stick with just one weapon set, you can just use these specialization points as bonus points to invest however you like
But creative players will find plenty of opportunities with this system
You can get weapon specialization points throughout the campaign from optional bosses and quests
For example, if I manage to defeat the Crowbell, I'll get a weapon specialization book
There are lots of other permanent boosts available from the campaign too
On the map you can see icons that indicate the many optional encounters you can find
Some of them have permanent character boosts and others have powerful items
If you're having trouble getting past a boss, it might be a good idea to explore and see what you can find
For example, if you defeat Blackjaw the Remnant, you'll gain a permanent increase to fire resistance
One of the most important finds are Spirit bonuses
You can find the first one here in the canopy in Act 1
Defeat the boss in this area to acquire a permanent addition of Spirit
The permanent buffs you gain from Spirit are very powerful and every class will find a use for them
So make sure you hunt down these upgrades. There's one in each Act
Now we haven't even talked about the most important element of character progression, items
That's why we're all here, right?
Items in Path of Exile can be broken down into four rarity groups
Normal, Magic, Rare and Unique
One of the things you're going to want to do as you play through the campaign is upgrade the items you find
And you can do that with currency items
An Orb of Transmutation will allow you to upgrade a normal item to a magic item with one mod
You can then apply an Orb of Augmentation to add a second mod
Then use a Regal Orb to add a third mod and upgrade it to a rare
Finally, you can use some Exalted Orbs to add more mods to your rare to a total of six mods
One of the things we think is really important is to make these options available to use as you play
All the items that add mods are much more common than they were in Path of Exile 1
So that you can use them throughout your campaign playthrough
We want you to find things on the ground that can be crafted into upgrades much more frequently
As well as making the drop rates on these items much more common
You can also get them by disenchanting unwanted gear at the magic item vendor
If you disenchant magic items you can build up to an Orb of Transmutation
And by disenchanting rares you can build up to Regal Orbs
Another important area of crafting items in POE 2 is sockets
Some items you find will have sockets that can have Esamite runes placed in them that add more mods to the item
If I insert this Glacial Rune into my helmet it will give extra cold resistance
This is a great way to solve problems that you have with your build like resistances or damage
If you find socketed items that you don't have a use for
You can take them to the salvage bench in town to work towards an Artifices Orb
This will allow you to add sockets to your existing items
Body armors and two-hand weapons can have up to two sockets
While the rest of your armor and one-hand weapons can only have one socket
You can also salvage items with quality to create items like armor scraps or whetstones
These will allow you to increase the quality of your items for an up to 20% boost
If you don't want to disenchant or salvage your items you can always sell them for gold
Gold can be used to buy items from vendors and we've tried to do a lot to make sure that the items they have for sale are actually useful
Every time you level up they get more stock so make sure to check back often
Other vendors offer a gamble
Pay a flat amount of gold and you'll get a random item of a specific type
This could be a great way to improve your gear if you're lucky
Gold is also used to respec your passive skills
Take advantage of this system to experiment with your tree and rework it as required
The other thing you might want to use gold for is the currency exchange
This allows you to exchange currency items with other players on an open market in exchange for a small gold fee
Now all items in Path of Exile are freely tradable
We never bind anything to your character except gold
Now most gear in Path of Exile 2 is randomly generated but there's another type that isn't
Uniques
They are especially rare, each with a handcrafted set of unusual mods which can dramatically change a character's build
They're not just better rare items, they can do much stranger things that can fundamentally change your character
Corpse Wade will make any corpses you run through explode into clouds of poison
The Sands of Silk is a body armor that changes your dodge roll into a blink, morphing you into sand as you teleport past your foes
And of course some uniques are just pure hits of dopamine, like Quill Reign, which just turns your bow attacks into full auto by doubling your attack speed
Each unique is something that you can build your character around
We try to make sure that most unique items have a potential use at endgame, even if you find them early on
And as you can see, every unique item has a potential use at endgame, even if you find them early on
The last character progression system that you can do during the campaign is Ascension
Starting in Act 2 you will come across Ascension trials, tests that you must complete to unlock your Ascension class
We'll explain these trials soon, but first let's take a look at what Ascending can do for your character
Each class has access to 3 Ascension classes, but at the start of early access only 2 per class will be available
Ascension classes are unique to each character class, so choose wisely, they can drastically affect how you build your character
As a sorceress you could become a Stormweaver, a master of the elements
Tempest Caller causes elemental storms to be summoned each time you do a critical hit with a spell
With Strike twice you can stack 2 copies of Shock for more damage
And going deeper into the tree you can make all your damage types apply Shock
Make a Shock build from any skill
Alternatively you could become a Chrono-mancer and command Time itself
She literally has the ability to stop time with Time Freeze
Not only that, but she has many other time manipulation abilities
Using Temporal Rift she can teleport back to a previous location, resetting her life and mana back to what it was
Or with Time Snap she can reset all her cooldowns and cast all her spells again
On the Warrior you can choose between the Warbringer or the Titan
The Warbringer channels the might of his ancestors to gain tremendous power
Using Answered Call you can summon ancestral spirits linked to each of your totems
With Jade Heritage you can encase your body in a protective layer that absorbs all damage until it breaks
Warcaller's Bellow allows you to explode the corpses of your enemies
And with Great Wolf's Howl you can ignore the cooldowns of your Warcries
Let all that anger out
The Titan class is all about hitting big
With Earthbreaker every slam is a chance to create an aftershock
With Crushing Impacts every hit becomes a crushing blow which will allow you to stun your enemies with ease
With Surprising Strength you can take advantage of stunned enemies to deal 40% more damage
As a Ranger you might choose to be a Deadeye, an expert markswoman who can take down foes with style
With Endless Munitions every attack gains an extra projectile
With Gathering Winds she gains a small increase to movement speed with every attack, but be careful, she loses them when getting hit
With Eagle Eyes she will never miss, allowing you to stop wasting all those passive points on accuracy
Alternatively you could become a Pathfinder, the master of flasks and poison
She can choose from one of several throwable concoctions, allowing her to spend her flask charges to throw explosive bottles that deal various types of damage
A Bleeding concoction will make your enemies bleed, while a Fulminating one can shock your enemies, allowing you to do extra damage
Contagious Contamination allows her to spread poisons between her foes, while Overwhelming Toxicity doubles the number of stacks they can be infected by
Running Assault allows her to move much more quickly while firing, while Relentless Pursuit makes her totally immune to being slowed by enemies
The Witch can ascend into the Infernalist or the Blood Mage
As an Infernalist she can summon a loyal Hellhound companion
The Hellhound sets enemies on fire, as well as taking a percentage of the damage if the Infernalist gets hit
With Pyromantic Pact you can turn your mana into Infernal Flame
As you cast more spells, the flame builds up and if it overflows you'll take damage
Using Bringer of Flame you'll want to make sure you keep the flames topped up
While your Infernal Flame is above 30% all damage from you and your minions will ignite enemies
She can also transform into a literal Demon
While in Demon form she takes an increasing amount of damage, but her cast speed and damage increase rapidly as well
So if you're planning on transforming into a Demon, make sure you stack a lot of life recovery
She can also become a Blood Mage, a master of life and energy
All Blood Mages must pay the price of making skills cost life as well as mana
But in exchange, every monster they kill will drop Life Remnants, which allow them to quickly gain back that life
With Crimson Power she can gain large amounts of extra life, and with Vitality Siphon she can use her spells to leech life back as well
Once you've got a significant amount of life, you can use Gore Spike to make your critical hits deal incredible amounts of damage
A Monk who is in tune with the elements might become an Invoker
With Elemental Expression the Invoker will create waves of elemental power each time he does a critical strike
With Faith as a choice you gain the ability to meditate, allowing you to double your energy shield
Choose between I Am the Blizzard or I Am the Thunder to specialize in cold or lightning
And I Shall Rage will allow you to turn into an unbound avatar
Each time you apply a status ailment to an enemy you gain unbound fury
When you have enough, transform into an avatar to deal way more damage and inflict even more elemental ailments
Some Monks choose to reach into the darkness instead
The Acolyte of Chaiula can exchange their Mastery of Spirit for Darkness, a resource that can be utilized to both absorb and deal damage
The Shroud of Darkness will protect you from all damage incoming, but if you take Grasp of the Void you will deal extra chaos damage from all the darkness you have
Their Dark Pact offers greatly increased resistances to chaos damage and can allow their mana leech to not only happen instantly, but apply to their energy shield as well
Another node you can take is Waking Dream, which allows you to see into the domain of the Breach Demons
There you will see the Flames of Chaiula that can be taken to gain life, mana and damage
The Mercenary has a job to do, but which job suits you? You might choose to become a Witch Hunter
Obsessive Rituals will give you a Sorcery Ward, allowing you to defend yourself against elemental hits in exchange for less defense against attacks
With Zealous Inquisition your enemies have a 10% chance to explode on death, the chance is doubled against Demons and Undead
With Judge, Jury and Executioner, your initial hit against enemies can deal up to 30% of their life in damage, if you're lucky
This is great for hunting powerful bosses
And with Witch Bane, you can break your enemies concentration, preventing them from casting spells as often as they would usually do
You could also choose to become a Gemling Legionnaire, enhancing your abilities by embedding gems directly in your flesh
Integrated Efficiency will give you extra skill slots
Thermatological Infusion gives you extra maximum resistances as you socket more and more support gems
Adaptive Capability allows you to use any color of gem without worrying about attributes, while Crystalline Potential adds extra quality bonuses to every gem socketed into your character
So those are the Ascenacy Classes for the start of Early Access, but one thing we haven't talked about yet is how you ascend in the first place
Ascension in Path of Exile 2 requires completion of one of the Great Trials, which you'll find as you progress through the campaign
Each one is associated with one of the major cultures of Rayclast
Located in the Vastari Plains are the Mara'Keth, a culture of rich tales and brutal traditions who must do whatever it takes to survive in the desert
The highest position in Mara'Keth culture is a Sekhema, and it is not a title given freely
All aspirants must complete the Trial of the Sekhemas, a grueling gauntlet that will test their strength, will, cunning and patience
To enter, a warrior of the Mara'Keth must prove their worth by trapping the soul of a djinn in a coin, and you are no different
Once you have earned your coin, it may be placed in the Relic Altar to begin the Trial
In the Trial of the Sekhemas, each room has its own challenges to overcome
In this room, each rare monster you kill will send its blood to the chalice in the center of the room
Once the chalice is filled, you will be able to proceed
While fighting monsters in the Trial, you will need to be very careful
Each hit will not only hurt you, but will damage your honor
The monsters are well telegraphed, so that you can avoid their attacks, but if you run out of honor, you will fail the Trial and need to find another coin in order to try again
It is a good idea to make sure that you are well prepared before challenging the Trial of the Sekhemas
After each room, you will be rewarded. In this case, you have been given a key that can be used to unlock chests later in the Trial
Once you have claimed your reward, you will be shown a map of the rest of the floor and may choose how you wish to proceed
Which challenges would you like to face, and which rewards do you want to claim?
Some rooms are more dangerous, afflicting you with debuffs that will persist for the entire Trial
For example, entering this room will afflict you with spiked shell that will cause all monsters in the rest of the Trial to have 50% increased life
You will want to take care if you choose such a path
There are many different challenges and rewards as you journey through the Trial
Deadly traps, waves of monsters, and strange artifacts will test your honor
As you progress, you will be able to gain boons from the Djinn, which will help you on your journey
For example, the Sekhemas Cloak will revive you once if you die, giving you a second shot at a run
One of the rewards you may find is Sacred Water, an extremely valuable and treasured resource to the Djinn and the Marraketh
Trading it with the Djinn will allow you to receive many benefits. You can recover honor, gain additional boons, or remove afflictions
At the end of the floor, you will find a powerful boss which will truly test your limitations
In order to ascend, you will need to defeat him
Having defeated the boss, you've earned the right to ascend, but first, the loot
The keys you have found may be used to open the various treasures in the vault at the end of the floor
We only have a single bronze key, so we'll just have to open one of these small chests
If you want to open the better ones, you'll need silver or gold keys
Let's use the Altar of Ascendancy. Your first ascension will allow you to pick your class and grant you two points to use in the tree
Now there are more floors and many more rewards that can be found within the Trial of the Sekhemas, but we'll save that for the section on the endgame
For now, let's talk about the second Ascendancy Trial, the Trial of Chaos
In Path of Exile 2, you can choose whichever trial you like to earn your ascension
Each culture on Rayclast had their own methods to ascend
If the Trial of the Sekhemas is not your kind of playstyle, or you're finding it too difficult, you could try another
You can gain all your ascension points from just one, or mix and match them. It's up to you
For early access, we will have two trials as options, with a third trial coming later for the full release
While exploring the Vaal jungle, you'll discover the Temple of Chaos
Before the Vaal embraced the science of corruption, their civilization worshipped chaos
This ancient trial was once used by the Vaal to test their high priests
A high priest of the Vaal must show willingness to risk everything to gain power
Entry to the trial requires a token from a strange entity known only as the Trialmaster
For those in which he sees potential, he shall inscribe and ultimate him
Many have attempted these trials in search of greatness, most have perished
Will you be able to defy the odds?
Before you begin each chamber, the Trialmaster will offer you a reward and a choice
Choose one of three tribulations to affect you through the rest of the trial
These modifiers might beef up the monsters, curse the player, or add environmental hazards like turrets or trap runes
In this case, we will be picking Shocking Turrets
As you enter the room, the Trialmaster will fill it with hazards to test your commitment
In this case, you must destroy all the monsters that fill the room, while dealing with the lightning projectiles from the Shocking Turrets
After each room, you will need to make a choice
Take the rewards you have earned so far, or go double or nothing
Increase your rewards, but take on more risk
Each tribulation you add is minor on its own, but they quickly stack on top of each other and can become overwhelming
There are many types of chambers in the trial, each will test your resolve in different ways
This one simply requires you to choose one of the three chambers to test your resolve
Each chamber will test your resolve in different ways
This one simply requires you to survive for a certain amount of time
Another requires you to escort the stone idol through the level as elevators full of monsters descend to attack you
Should you be able to get through the first three chambers, you will face your first boss
The order of the bosses is random, and combined with the tribulations you have selected, the fight will never feel the same
After defeating the boss, you may claim your rewards
Of course there are the items, but you also gain the right to ascend
If you already did the trial of the secondments, then you can claim two more points to add to your ascendancy class
Now it's possible to go much deeper, there are more bosses, rewards and risks to take, but we'll talk more about that when we get to endgame
So how about we talk about that now?
So far we've only been showing you footage from the campaign, but some people would argue that the endgame is where the game truly begins
Something that happens almost every time a new action RPG launches is people saying, there isn't enough endgame content
Well, we want to make sure that in Peewee 2 people don't feel that way, and we actually only changed our development priority for this recently
The first three acts of Peewee 2 already take around 25 hours to complete if you're a new player
This is already a pretty significant campaign
On the other hand, people spend hundreds of hours in endgame each league
We realised that finishing the rest of the campaign for early access was actually a bad idea
Instead of having acts 4-6 in early access, we could concentrate on endgame and make that great
For new players, a 25 hour campaign is already a huge game with lots of content
But for existing action RPG players, what you mostly care about is all the endgame challenges to overcome
So several months ago we switched the entire development team's focus over to making endgame content
At the start of early access there will be 50 bosses and around 100 new characters
And around 400 monster types, but the great thing is that the rest of the game is like 80% there
We'll be adding content to roughly double the size of the game during early access and inter-release
Now in order to make the endgame happen at the same character level as what it would be after we added the rest of the acts
We've added a second difficulty level called Cruel, where you repeat the campaign with all the monsters and bosses levelled up
And of course new rewards
You can kind of think of it as like a new game plus
It's also a lot faster to get through the content the second time as your clear speed increases
That will take you to around level 65 where the endgame begins
Once we add the remaining three acts we'll be removing Cruel difficulty
So you'll progress straight from the Intervax 6 to endgame
But what is the endgame?
To explain that I'll hand over to Mark, he can tell you all about it
Hi, I'm Mark Roberts, game director on Path of Exile 2
Well, one thing that Path of Exile is known for is having a lot of distinct endgame content to choose between
Each endgame mechanic needs to have its own progression system, areas, bosses, rewards and player power that can only be gained from that content
We are going to be adding a lot more over time, but for Path of Exile 2 we decided to start with seven distinct systems you can progress through
This is the Atlas, and it serves as the core of the endgame for Path of Exile 2
It's infinite and expands in all directions
Now we are not going to spoil the plot too much here, but corruption from the beast has blighted the land and your objective is to help fight it
In the center of the Atlas you will find the Ziggurat, a temple in which the Vaal research the fundamentals of space and time
Here we can open portals to nearby locations and begin cleansing corruption and finding resources
In order to power the portal device we will need waystones
Each waystone has a tear which will determine the level of the monsters that you will face
To go to an area simply click one that is adjacent to an area that you have already completed
Insert the waystone and click traverse
Portals will open allowing you and your party to travel to the area you have selected
All the areas in the endgame feel distinct from the locations in the campaign and we have dialled the randomisation up to 11
The monster packs you will face in each map are totally random and the combination of them can lead to some very interesting combat situations
There are over 400 monster types in early access and they have a lot of varied and interesting abilities
Depending on which combinations you face you might find some serious challenges
In order to cleanse the corruption from the area you will need to defeat all the powerful rare and unique enemies in it
Once you have done that the area will be marked as completed and you will be able to travel past it to progress deeper into the world
If you die then the map can no longer be run and you will have to find another way around to get to the areas behind it
There are also all kinds of other random encounters you might run into as you play maps
One such encounter are precursor artefacts. These are ancient, corrupting monuments that irradiate the monsters around them
The monsters that feed off the corruption are drawn to their power
If you defeat the monsters and cleanse the artefact you will get a powerful temporary buff
Some of the buffs make you faster, others rain lightning or fire around you and some even give you increased experience or help you find better items
You can also find strong boxes. These enigmatic chests guard piles of treasure but are always a trap
Monsters lie in wait to attack you the moment you open it and the boxes often have mechanisms to unleash powerful spells or dangerous debuffs
There are different types of strong boxes containing different items and you can even use your currency items to craft them on the fly so you can optimise the content
But be careful of opening one you can't handle
Sometimes you'll discover monsters frozen in essences, solidified crystalline corruption
These dangerous monsters can be broken free. If you defeat them, the essence they drop can be used to upgrade normal items to magic items with a guaranteed mod from a category
For example, we could use this one on some boats to ensure a movement speed mod
Rarely, essences will also drop that allow you to upgrade magics to rares adding the guaranteed mod
This is incredibly powerful since it allows you to get a second deterministic mod in your crafting projects
Combining these with the currencies that are commonly found at Rayclast for modifying items and we can get a very nice pair of boots indeed
Waitstones, like all items, can also be crafted using your currency items
Adding prefix mods will improve the rewards while suffix mods will make it easier to craft items
The more dangerous a map is, the more waystones will drop
Adding mods to your waystones is key to progressing to higher tiers and sustaining them, but it will require you to take on larger challenges
There are a variety of factors you have to consider when crafting your waystones
Some maps will have higher density, some lower, some have more magic and rare chests, more monsters, some are more linear and others more open
Make sure you explore and think about what makes certain maps good if you want to maximise your returns
As you cleanse corruption from higher and higher tiers of the atlas, you will gain points that you can spend in the atlas tree
This tree allows you to juice the danger and rewards of all areas in the endgame
You could increase the number of monsters, the number of rares, the number of precursor artifacts or strongboxes, even the quantity of items you can get
As you explore the endgame world map, you will notice various different biomes, from snowcapped mountains to dense jungle valleys
Most maps are restricted to certain biomes
As you continue to explore deeper into the atlas, there are all sorts of things to discover
These cities are constructed by different peoples of Rayclust and have specific items that can be found there
These strange structures marked on the map don't appear to be the same as the other maps you have seen
These strange structures marked on the map don't appear to do anything for now, perhaps you'll work out how to use them later
You might find unique maps like Untainted Paradise, an undisturbed island full of beasts that give an extreme amount of experience
You may even find a lonely man just enjoying his retirement who will give you a unique item for free
In addition, you can find special areas that would make a good spot to set up camp
Clear these areas off their hostile inhabitants and you'll be able to claim them as your own hideout
You can decorate your hideout as you see fit and invite various NPCs to join you there to create your own personal base of operations
A great tool for exploration are towers
These mysterious precursor constructs are dotted around the atlas
Completing the tower will reveal a large area around it, allowing you to scout out your next challenge
There are lots of things to find, so keep looking
Some sections of your atlas are influenced by corruption
This adds extra modifiers to the maps in the region, increasing difficulty and rewards
Here, slaying monsters in close proximity to each other will cause the vestiges of corruption within them to merge together, forming powerful and grotesque abominations
You may have noticed while looking at the atlas that some of the areas have these icons above them
The icon indicates that the area contains some kind of special encounter
This icon indicates that the area has a powerful boss
Because only 1 in 4 maps contain a map boss, we are able to make them very powerful and very rewarding
These bosses come from the campaign, but have had their difficulty increased with changes to AI and some of their abilities
It's worth noting that because you can see where the bosses are, you can choose to take them on or avoid them
If you do choose to hunt bosses though, then you will be rewarded with special points for the boss hunting section of the Atlas skill tree
The points here will allow you to specialise in boss killing, giving you much greater rewards for defeating them
For each different type of content in the endgame, we are adding specialised trees in order to make it so you don't feel the need to re-spec your points when you change between different types of content
We will be showing you 7 of these by the end of this presentation, so there is still a lot more to come
Bosses are not the only icon you will see on the Atlas, let's take a look at one of the endgame systems, Breach
If you played PoE 1, you might be familiar with Breach
For PoE 2 we have created sequels to several PoE 1 leagues
While the mechanic is familiar, the monsters, bosses, rewards and progression are all new
A breach is a tear in the fabric of reality, opening it will allow you to see the demons and otherworldly monstrosities that lie in wait on this other plane of existence
By engaging with a breach, you will create a bridge between their world and Rayclast
In order to keep the breach open, you will need to kill the demons that pour forth
The faster you can kill the monsters, the more monsters you will fight and the more loot you will find
You can also find clasped hands that will open and drop more items if you run over them
These can be a good boost to the rewards of the breach, so keep an eye out
One of the rewards that you may find while fighting monsters from Breach are tablets
Tablets are special items that can be used with precursor towers to add more encounters to the Atlas
Breaches will drop Breach tablets
Clicking on a completed tower will allow you to consume the tablet to add more breaches to areas within range of the tower
This makes all the content in the Atlas self-sustaining
Want to do more breaches? Find the tablets, add them to your towers, get more breaches, getting more tablets
Soon your Atlas will be covered in otherworldly domains
In addition, like all items in PoE, you can craft them
Use your currency to add mods to your tablets, allowing you to upgrade all the breaches in range
Tablets can have up to two mods
These mods do things like adding extra rare monsters, extra clasped hands, or even mods to density of breaches, allowing you to keep them open longer
Often you will find multiple towers near to each other with overlapping areas of effect
This can allow you to rarely juice the mechanic by stacking them up to the top of the tower
This can allow you to rarely juice the mechanic by stacking the mods from multiple tablets
In your fight to hold the Breach demons at bay, you may want to use the powers of their world against them
Each end game mechanic always has player power that can only be gained from that mechanic, and Breach is no different
In Breach you will find catalysts, items that can increase the quality of rings and amulets by improving specific mods
You can also find Breach Rings, a special base type that can have its quality improved by catalysts up to 50%
In this case you could create a ring with around 170 life
Breach rings can become some of the strongest rings in the game, giving you some good motivation to face the demon hordes
In addition, each end game mechanic needs to have a pinnacle end game encounter
While killing Breach monsters you may find Breach Splinters
Collect enough of these and you'll be able to create a Breach Stone
Using a Vaal technology called the Realm Gate, you can use your Breach Stone to access their domain and bring the fight to them
In this twisted domain you will find nothing but a single massive Breach
Triggering it will reveal hordes of Breach inhabitants
And should you be fast enough, you will be able to fight their leader, Zest, We That Are One
This is just one of the pinnacle encounters of POE 2
We won't be showing the rest of them, so you will have to discover them for yourself
But rest assured, this is some of the hardest content we have ever made
All of these encounters have spent a lot of time and effort to create a pinnacle encounter
And we hope you enjoyed it
We will be showing the rest of them, so you will have to discover them for yourself
But rest assured, this is some of the hardest content we have ever made
All of these encounters have specific uniques that can only be found from them
But that's not all, we still have the progression system
Defeating Zest will give you points to allocate into the Breach section of the Atlas Tree
Allocating these points will make Breaches and the Breach domain even harder, but will give you more rewards
The small nodes will increase the difficulty of the Twisted Domain, while the large nodes have more specific bonuses
For example, this node adds more Clasped Hands to your Breaches, and adds a pack of magic monsters that can guard them
Get some more points and you can allocate Waking Nightmare, which will double the number of splinters you get from Clasped Hands
And inflict you with a mysterious debuff
In order to earn more points you will need to defeat Zest at a higher difficulty
And some rewards from Zest can only be found by increasing the difficulty of the Twisted Domain above certain thresholds
Defeating Zest at difficulty 4 will be a challenge indeed, but there are many more threats in Rayclass
Ritual Altars are sacrificial sites, built by the mysterious King in the Mists
If you encounter this symbol on the Atlas, then you know that the area contains Ritual Altars
Ritual Altars demand tribute
Every monster you slaughter in the circle will feed the altar
After the sacrifice, touch it to begin the ritual
The monsters you just killed will be resurrected by the King of the Mists' dark magic, and you must fight to survive
The tribute you have offered to the altar can be spent to buy powerful items, but they can be expensive
To gain more tribute you will want to find more altars
Each successive ritual you do within an area will spawn the monsters revived by the previous ones, in addition to the ones you sacrifice next to it
By the end of an area you will be fighting a truly imposing number of foes, but will have a significant amount of tribute to spend
One of the rewards you can buy with tribute are Omens
These are special items that allow for meta-crafting
Crafting items that affect other crafting items
Have an item with good prefixes but bad suffixes?
This omen will help you to remove the mods you don't want while keeping the ones you do
There are a bunch more of these with different effects, but we will leave them for you to discover
Now don't forget that Ritual will also drop tablets, which can be used to specialize into getting more rituals
If you want to get to the Pinnacle boss of Ritual, then you will probably want to use them
They can also be crafted to grant mods, making your rituals more rewarding
The Pinnacle encounter of Ritual is the King in the Mists
Feared by the Asmiri people, he is said to have brought eternal darkness to the Wildwood
We won't show the encounter, but just like Breach, there are a range of unique items you can get for defeating him
And you will gain points in the Ritual section of the Atlas Tree
Some maps have been touched by insanity
A mysterious entity has taken a special interest in you
Step through the Looking Glass and you will find your nightmares coming to life
When you touch a mirror, the mists of Delirium will spread out across the area, infecting your mind
You must stay within the mist to maintain the nightmare, which is as profitable as it is terrifying
Everything you kill will increase the rewards that drop
However, the deeper into the mist you travel, the stronger the monsters are
Be careful not to overstay your welcome
Rare and unique enemies will become vessels for terrifying demons
Who will manifest out of them to unleash powerful attacks on you
The mist also offers a strange crafting material, Distilled Emotions
By combining these emotions you are able to instill your amulet with a notable from the passive skill tree
This is like gaining an extra passive point for free attached to your gear
They are also particularly great because you don't have to traverse the tree to get them
Allowing you to get off-class bonuses that would normally be much harder to get
Distilled Emotions can also be used to instill your endgame maps
Applying Delirious to them and adding additional difficulty and rewards
Allowing you to further juice your endgame maps
The tablets you can find from Delirium can be used to further improve it
Increase pack size, make the fog dissipate slower, or improve your progress towards the pinnacle encounter of Delirium
Speaking of which, every now and then you will find Simulacrum Splinters
The mysterious entity will create strange encounters based on warped versions of your own memories
Monsters and Simulacrums come in waves that get progressively more difficult
You will receive loot at the end of each wave and you will have to make the decision to leave now or continue on
Facing up against even tougher foes from the mist
The bosses you will face as you get deeper into a Simulacrum are truly terrifying
If you can complete a Simulacrum, you will gain points for the Delirium section of the Atlas Skill Tree
Next up we have Expedition
Occasionally while clearing Corruption, you will encounter these Kal-Gurren settlers
The Kal-Gurrens have discovered ancient burial sites with lost Verisium artifacts
And they want you to help dig them up with explosives
The Kal-Gurrens have marked the locations where the relics can be found
Place explosives as best you can to dig up as many as possible
There is just one problem
Corruption has brought the corpses of their ancestors to life
So you might have to do a little clean up before you can reclaim the artifacts
You can also find Remnants
The destruction of which will further anger the restless dead
Each one you blow up will make the subsequent monsters more powerful but also more rewarding
Danug, Rog, Tujun and Gwennan will exchange the artifacts for useful items and runic magic
You can also find tablets to increase the number of expeditions and the rewards
This one increases the radius of explosives
While this one increases the number of remnants you will find
Eventually you might discover a Logbook
These are special maps full of buried treasure and relics
Essentially one giant dig site
Here you can create an extremely long chain of explosives and go through a very high number of remnants
But be careful
Many remnants have mods that can really break your build
So you will probably want to avoid these ones
If you add too many remnants you could easily make the encounter harder than you can handle
There are all sorts of interesting things buried under the ground in Logbooks
You might find dripping caves and hidden pirate caches
But the most powerful encounter is Olroth, the ancient undead commander of the Knights of the Sun
Defeating him will grant you unique rewards as well as points to spend in the expedition section of the Atlas tree
So those are the endgame systems on the Atlas but we are not done yet
The trials we talked about earlier have much more content when you get to endgame 2
Just like the other endgame systems, they also have progression mechanics, unique rewards and player power that can only be gained from them
As you get higher level coins for the trial of the Sekimas, you will unlock more floors to explore
Each floor has its own challenging brooms and a floor boss that you will need to kill
There are four floors in total, leading to another pinnacle boss at the end of the last floor which can only be accessed at endgame
The trial of the Sekimas is where you'll find jewels, which you can socket into your tree
These are like passives that you can craft with your currency items
They can be really powerful as they allow you to stack modifiers that may not be easily accessible on the tree normally
This jewel gives lightning damage and shock chance for example
There are quite a few jewel sockets on the tree so it's possible to gain a lot of power here
There are also other types of jewels that don't provide any bonuses themselves but affect other passives surrounding them
This jewel increases the effect of small nodes and radius by 25%
With careful placement in the tree, you could get a significant amount of power from it
There are also unique jewels available with very interesting effects, but you will have to find those for yourself
In order to push further into the trial and uncover the secrets of the Marakev, you will want to take advantage of its progression system, relics
Relics are items that can be placed in the relic altar as you start the trial
They give special bonuses that affect the trial, making it easier and increasing its rewards
Of course, you can craft these with your currency items, making them even stronger
If you can complete the entire trial overcoming all four floors, the final boss will reward you with one of many unique relics
These relics will be consumed when used on your next run, but can reward you with unique and powerful items
For example, this is the Last Flame
If you use it, you will have only one honor for the entire trial, so you will need to do a completely hitless run
The Trial of Chaos also extends into the endgame
As you gain inscribed ultimatums of higher and higher levels, the number of chambers that you can go through increases
In true Vaal style, this allows you to take even more risks for even more rewards
At endgame, you can progress through up to 10 chambers with 3 bosses on a single run
Stacking 10 tribulations on top of each other will make this a significant challenge, but it's worth it
The Trialmaster will tempt you with items of the Vaal empire, such as Vaal Orbs
Vaal Orbs are powerful crafting items that corrupt your gear with random mysterious outcomes
Corruption prevents an item from being modified further, so it has to be the last step of your craft, but it's also the most impactful one
For example, if you use one on your body armor, it might add a new powerful enchantment, or it might reroll up to half of its modifiers
Vaal Orbs also have the ability to add a socket, allowing you to bypass the normal restriction of how many sockets an item can have
A body armor could get up to 3 sockets this way, allowing for a significant number of mods
Vaal Orbs can even modify uniques
Adding enchantments or sockets to uniques can make them incredibly powerful, but there is a good chance that you will break them as well
The Trialmaster will also occasionally offer you Soul Cores
Originally formed by Chaos, the Vaal sought to replicate Soul Cores through human sacrifice rituals and blood magic to power their civilization
Soul Cores are powerful socketable items, with mods that cannot be obtained from regular runes
Like all endgame content, there is of course a pinnacle boss
The final chamber will drop keys to this mysterious door
Some say this is where the Trialmaster himself resides
Perhaps you are willing to take the risk to find out
Had enough yet? Because there is still just one more thing
The most difficult content in Path of Exile 2
While mapping you might come across this fortress that has emerged from underground, surrounded by an enormous maze riddled with danger
Is the maze preventing something from getting in? Or something getting out?
This fortress is of ancient origin and its construction has similarities to the towers and tablets that you have been using on your journey through the endgame
It is clear from the entrance that there are 3 keys required to enter
Local factions are vying for access to the fortress in order to seize the power they believe will be inside
Each of the faction's leaders have managed to get their hands on one of the keys, so you will need to defeat them
Each faction is led by an Uber Act boss
You can see one of them inhabiting the city, but in order to fight him you will first need to defeat their 2 lieutenants in the adjacent zones
Be careful, if you fail against either of the lieutenants or to kill the leader they will move on and you will need to find them again
Kill all the Uber bosses and you will gain access to the fortress
We aren't going to spoil it as we can't wait to see you guys attempt it for the first time
But is there a tree you get points in after killing it? Of course there is. This is Path of Exile, there is always another tree
So these are your challenges for POE 2. As you can see, this project is crazy huge, way bigger than even we expected when we started out
But how do you gain access?
Well, during early access you will need a key to get in
To thank our existing POE supporters who have spent more than $480 USD, we will be giving you guys a key for the PC version for free
Anyone else who wants one can get one by purchasing one of the new early access supporter packs that have just been released to the store
If you just want early access to POE 2, then you can get a key in the $30 USD early access pack
The pack also comes with $30 USD of points to spend in the MTX store
But we also have a variety of other supporter packs filled with exclusive microtransactions, points to spend in the store and even physical items
The cosmetics can be used right now in POE 1 and in Path of Exile 2 in early access starts
Most of this footage has been recorded in Path of Exile 1, since that's where you can use them immediately
The Lord of Ogham supporter pack contains a cosmetic armour set befitting of the Count of Ogham himself
There is also a matching back attachment which has an alternate variant depicting the influence of corruption
Also in this pack you can find a portal formed of the rusted armour of the fallen soldiers in the Red Veil of Ogham
And the offspring of a vicious crowbell boss found in the hunting grounds
This one doesn't look so vicious though
On top of that you'll receive the Iron Counts as Y-Hander to apply to your one-handed or two-handed swords
For those who are wanting to decorate your hideouts with fond memories and tales of Path of Exile's history
You will also get a series of hideout statues
This pack contains the Statue of Hillock
For Path of Exile 1's closed beta, each pack contained a true New Zealand icon, the Kiwi
Following this tradition, all packs in this series will also contain a new themed Kiwi pet
The pet will loyally follow you into battle, but run away at the first sign of trouble
Become the ruler of the desert with the King of the Faridun supporter pack
Show your mastery of traversing the sands of the Vasteri Plains
The body armour will allow you to glide along the ground with ancient sand magic
Now each armour set comes with body armour, boots, gloves and helmet
But the boots are covered in sand
If you'd prefer to show them off, you can turn the gliding off if you want
The accompanying back attachment equips you with two powerful pillars that can control and manipulate lightning
They will periodically release their energy in a powerful blast while in town
And hover in a circle around you, arcing lightning between them forming a barrier of energy
Replace the appearance of any bow with the Faridun's glory skin
Or replace the appearance of a spear with the Tyranese End Spear skin
This spear skin can be applied to staves and war staves in Path of Exile 1
If you want to truly show your worth as a King of the Faridun, then you definitely need your trusty, moving, entire city fortress known as the Dreadnought to travel across the Vasteri Plains
In Path of Exile you can decorate your hideout however you like, and it's no exception here
It comes with a variety of thematic elements to use, or use decorations from elsewhere in the game
Additionally, you will get the Deshret's Blessing Level Up effect
The King of the Faridun Kiwi Pet
And last but not least, a statue depicting the Vaal Oversoul from Path of Exile 1
For those who don't know how our supporter packs work, each pack comes with all of the cosmetics from the previous tier
So you will get all the items from the Lord of Ogham supporter pack as well
The Thaumaturge of the Vaal supporter pack features an armour set and back attachment themed around the Vaal and their pursuit of science and progress
You can find the Soul Core Weapon effect in this pack, which causes Thaumaturgic energy harnessed from sacrifice to spill from your weapon
This pack also contains Doryani's Idol
It replaces the default appearance of any foci to an ancient relic once used by Doryani, and this can be applied to shields in Path of Exile 1
That's not the only Vaal weapon you'll find, it also contains the Wand of the Thaumaturge skin, and the Royal Sacrifice Dagger skin
You wouldn't think to put sacrificial gems on a Kiwi, but the Vaal did
Thaumaturge of the Vaal supporters will receive the Thaumaturge of the Vaal Kiwi Pet, and the Statue of Dominus
This is also the first pack in the series with a physical item
When purchasing this pack you'll receive a Path of Exile 2 logo t-shirt, but if you don't want one, you can opt out and return for additional points to spend in the store
Becoming a Warlord of the Kaerui supporter will grant you an armour set and back attachment, adorned in jade carvings and iridescent feathers resembling power
Enough to even impress the ancestral gods, specifically Tuukohama, the Kaerui god of war
Overkill you say? I think the Kaerui people would disagree
Why not drop a gigantic totem on rare enemies you slay to crush them to a pulp?
Replace your crafting bench in your hideout with the Ancestral Canoe crafting bench, where Ancestral Chief Marta will summon a giant canoe manned by Kaerui warriors to aid in your crafting desires
You'll also get a pair of weapon skins
Equip Akoya's Falling Axe skin to your one-handed or two-handed axes, or Tuukohama's Crusher to your one-handed or two-handed maces
A true Kaerui Warlord is always accompanied by their trusty Kiwi
Once one of the most feared beings in Rayclass, Malachai was slain by a powerful Exile
May the statue commemorate the virtue of Exile's past, present and of the future
Of course it's not all about dressing up in game, you'll want to look good in real life too
By becoming a Warlord, you'll be able to get a lot of experience and experience
You'll be able to get a lot of experience and experience
Of course it's not all about dressing up in game, you'll want to look good in real life too
By becoming a Warlord of the Kaerui supporter, you'll also get a Path of Exile 2 hoodie
Our final tier of supporter pack in this series is the Liberator of Rayclass supporter pack
The Liberator of Rayclass armour set and back attachment come made with the finest materials in Rayclass, and shattered glass mosaics suspended in divine power
Set up your base of operations in the Beacon of Salvation hideout
Why restrict yourself to just one island when you can liberate more?
The Beacon of Salvation hideout comes equipped with your own collection of small islands and personal operators of boats that you can use to row between them
Just walk to the piers, click a boat to enter and navigate as you choose
Decorate each island as you see fit to best represent your well-earned hideout
Everyone in your hideout can use their own boat, why not have some races?
You can also get the Window to Twilight portal effect
A beautiful mosaic piece of art that shatters and reveals a gateway to your desired destination as you approach it
As you walk away, the glass magically reforms back to its original form
Rule in style with the Throne of the Ruler map device
Sure, this map device can create portals to endgame maps, but it also comes with a throne you can sit on to oversee your growing kingdom
Look down on the plebeians running your maps
Being the Liberator though is not just about sitting in your throne all day
If you do decide to join the fight yourself, you can leave a high priest in charge to second in command
Liberator of Rayclass supporters will also get a set of varied weapon skins
The Light of Divinity Scepter skin
The Deliverance Crossbow skin
The Justice Flail skin
And the Redemption Shield skin
Once again you'll have an accompanying Kiwi, and of course a statue depicting one of the most iconic events in Rayclass's history
The battle between a powerful Exile and Kitava, the insatiable
With the help of two deities, Sin and Innocence, the Exile was able to defeat him once and for all
This supporter pack also contains the Path of Exile 2 artbook
This 215 page full colour artbook includes a huge amount of amazing concept art and lore produced during the long and exciting journey of Path of Exile 2's development
And finally, Path of Exile has a tradition of letting the community participate in designing game features
For Path of Exile 2 we'll be adding the Twilight Order Foil Reliquary
By becoming a Liberator of Rayclass supporter, once Path of Exile 2 is released you will be able to select any unique item you have found and be able to drop it from the Reliquary
Once players have submitted their items, keys to the Reliquary will start dropping
And other players will be able to find foil versions of uniques that you have submitted along with a message for the lucky player
The more players submit the same unique, the more chances there will be for the Reliquary to drop them, so choose wisely
Now almost all of these items are available to use in POE 1 right now
There are a few exceptions where the item class clearly doesn't exist, such as crossbows or flails
And there are also a few microtransactions on weapon types that are unavailable in POE 2 at the start of early access
Once classes that use those weapon types are added, those microtransactions will be available to use
If you can't decide which supporter pack to choose yet, you can always start with the Early Access Supporter Pack that just includes a key and some points to spend in the store
Then you can upgrade to any of the following tiers at a later date
These Supporter Packs will be available for purchase throughout early access
We'd really like to thank you for your ongoing support. Without you guys, Path of Exile 2 could not have happened
Now, I'm sure you guys have a lot of questions. Stick around, because coming up next we have a live Q&A with Ziggy D
Welcome to the post show discussion and Q&A. I hope you all enjoyed what you've seen so far
It's been pretty exciting for us here as well as you guys have been inspired already just watching things
And you're already cooking a new ascendancy class
Yeah, for sure
You've got to do design whenever you can
Absolutely, there's been a few fun moments here already
I'm your host Ziggy D and I'm joined by Jonathan and Mark to talk about everything you've seen
Honestly, it's so much
I mean, we were really keen to make sure that when we went into early access that people didn't feel like it was just limping along and kind of just like a minimum amount of content
We really wanted to kind of blow people away. So hopefully people feel like, yeah, there is enough content
Because it was certainly a mission to get all that stuff in
Yeah, I did come here expecting that there would be, you know, maybe a basic mapping placeholder end game and your three acts and, you know, the half the classes
But you've made a decision here, clearly, that's got to go the core POE player community in mind
Absolutely. So, I mean, we have to make sure like, I mean, look, Path of Exile's end game is kind of known for the fact you get to choose between different types of content and that like, you know, some people enjoy one thing, some people enjoy another
And I feel like that choice is like a huge part of what makes it good. So if we didn't have that when we entered the end game, then I don't think that would be, you know, like that wouldn't be a Path of Exile end game
So that's kind of what we have to make sure of. So we kind of said, okay, well, like, what is the minimum number of like different end game things you need to be able to have in order to be able to actually have a viable end game that you feel like you get different choices?
And that's how we ended up with what we have here
I definitely feel like a lot of games nowadays release, you know, and their campaigns intact real good, you get to the end game and it just falls real flat
And it was certainly a very important moment for us when we were like, hold on, that's the wrong thing to do. Like, let's not make the same mistake as everyone else, let's pivot. And we actually did that and like, it made a world of difference and made the game all of a sudden, you know, a hundred times bigger with an infinite amount more content, right?
It was definitely hard though, because like, okay, like, so we're, you know, we're progressing, it's like, we would have made it, we would have gotten, you know, all these acts in if we hadn't have changed direction. It's like to actually say, you know what, we're going to specifically not finish this content we'll be working on, you know, that we, you know, it's like pens down everyone, we're stopping work on this, we're going to move over to end games is actually more important. Like that was certainly a hard one.
That would have been some whiplash there, I imagine.
I mean, it's like suddenly the whole, you know, like environment art team, it's like, you know, they're all just like, whatever you're working on, just scrap, you don't want to scrap, but you know, just stop it. We're doing something else now.
Saving clothes, yeah.
Especially for a lot of the developers, because you got to also think like a lot of our developers have just been working on this campaign for, what is it now, six years.
I think it's even longer.
Yeah, it's like just this epic journey. Whereas none of them, you know, a lot of these people haven't been working on Path of Exile 1 this whole time.
So some of us are like, you know, we're just churning out end game with every league and doing all of that. But for a lot of these people, a lot of these developers, yeah, it was quite jarring to swap over.
But everyone embraced it, you know, we talked about it, everyone was happy about it and stoked about it and it just ended up coming out real awesome.
I think it's landed well and it definitely kind of blew me away when you, even before I saw anything, we were in the car on the drive here and you were just info dumping all of the end game.
You're like, oh, we've got this feature, we've got this feature. I'm getting dopamine just from hearing about it. I haven't even seen anything yet.
But do you guys feel like you're competing against yourselves a little bit here? Because Path of Exile's kind of set the bar.
The original game has set the bar for what is available to end game in a game like this.
And it makes it's not acceptable really to launch with just nothing in terms of end game now.
Absolutely. I mean, yeah, I mean, like if you're not competing with yourself, then I don't think you're going to make good progress. Right. So that's what you really have to do.
Yeah. But cracking that out for beta even.
Yep, absolutely. I just think it would not have landed nearly as well without that.
And I think it's important that our existing Path of Exile 1 community feels like they're also served.
Like, yeah, sure, we're doing all this stuff for new players and that's really important and that'll expand the audience.
But, you know, if we launched and all the PUE1 players are unhappy, that wouldn't be good.
So, you know, we have to make sure that they also feel like, you know, they've got a game for both them and for all the new players we hope to bring to the genre.
And you definitely want all those different axes as well. Like just having two, right?
You'll get a lot of a lot of content can be immediately divisive, right?
Obviously, that's the nature of it. That's how it goes. Right.
And so you have all of these different avenues because there are different players who like different types of content.
So if you just say here's your one end game system. Well, immediately then there is a proportion of players who decide, I don't want this.
Right. And so having all of these options is like ultra key. And that is what Path of Exile 1 has taught us.
And again, it's like I'd say lessons learned for the genre and it is expanding and other games and stuff.
But, yeah, certainly, as you said, competing with ourselves. Yes, PUE1 has, you know, 40 axes, you know, and we've got seven really good ones here and obviously more to come.
But seven is a lot, mind you.
Especially when it's all like, you know, like people have to learn a lot of things again.
It's going to be very interesting to see how long it takes people to do the kind of difficulty for pinnacle content.
Yeah, yeah. It's like we have to. It's honestly like we actually don't even really know because like you never know what people are going to find in terms of builds and so on.
Like I'm hoping that it will take people a while to be able to work it out. But, you know, you never know.
Maybe end of day one people just, oh, yeah, easy. No problem.
You know, could be what it's like.
There are a few people that are doing that sort of thing. I saw like a solo cell phone level 100 in 24 hours or something.
Geez. OK, we got this is where we've got it now, is it?
So I imagine there'll be a little bit of a soft reset there for a reloading period.
There's stuff to learn.
And I mean, POE 2 has changed a lot over the years, so more than five years of development now.
And what was that initial pitch when POE 2 was first put forwards, like as to what it's going to be?
Because it was much smaller in scope originally.
Yeah. So when we started, it wasn't even a sequel. It was just we're just updating the character rigs.
And over time, it kind of feature creeped into a proper into a proper scene.
But the thing that we were saying is whenever we were talking about it, and I guess this is the main thing, is that we're like, OK, when we make an area here,
it needs to be that there's like a theme for it. It feels unique from everything else.
We're not going to just like have recycled stuff like within the campaign that just feels like, oh, you know, we just took this area and modified it slightly.
You know, each one's got to have its own stuff.
It's got to have monsters that were like carefully thought about that, like, you know, fit in with the world.
And it's got to have bosses that are actually like good tier quality, you know, every area is going to have one.
And so those decisions has kind of been things that have meant that like they really raised the quality bar to a level that took us way longer than we even really expected.
Like the those things there just like they it's huge. Right.
Like honestly, I feel like we underestimated significantly what it would take to deliver that level of quality.
I remember really early on a battle I fought for.
And I mean, like way back was like, if you think back to say Diablo 2, which obviously still holds a lot of power in terms of design motivations and philosophy and stuff within the company,
you get things like the super uniques and PRW1 did them.
And it's just like, here's a boss with one or two skills.
And I remember very, very, very early on in PRW2.
I'm like, I want every single boss to be memorable and a thing.
I don't want a unique monster that's just like dies in two seconds and uses heavy strike and has a fancy name.
And I remember I even got some push back at the time and thinking like, you know, I love the bosses, my favorite part of everything.
And so I was just like, I really don't want this.
This is just terrible.
And but of course, that decision, me pushing for that, me wanting that turned into this megalithic.
Now we have 50 aiming to be 100.
Honestly, probably later several more 100 once all the end games, everything start to evolve and more expansions comes out.
And I'm like, yep, we maybe just made, you know, 100 times more work for ourselves,
but 100 percent bloody worthwhile because I'd say those bosses are one of the main, you know, attraction pieces of the game.
And if anyone who plays it is just like, holy crap, those boss fights are amazing.
So like, you know, obviously some bad and some are good to different people and all that.
That's how it all goes. That's part of all the fun.
But it is true that me pushing for that thing literally created thousands and thousands and thousands of hours of work.
Now worthwhile work.
It's worthwhile work.
But it is again, that exact thing of like this.
The scope is kind of small on numerous axes.
And as we just raised and raised the quality bar to what we thought was good, it certainly went from, you know, what was it initially?
Just rescuing some character classes and new rigs or whatever into this like mega scale and high campaign.
Yeah, everything.
Full standalone separate game.
Yeah, fun, fun other anecdotes since we went out of that territory, it was originally codenamed Project Chimera.
What? I don't know.
It was this pipe dream.
I've never been a fan of these code name things.
It was this like, there were times way back in the original office, there was all this like, sometimes there'll be a feature you can't really do in Peewee One.
And it was always like, ah, we'll do it in Project Chimera.
That was like amongst the developers.
And people were like, what the heck is that?
Now, ironically, there is a boss in Act 3 called, well, it's got a different name, but it's called the Chimera internally.
It is a Chimera. It's a multi headed beast.
And you've seen in a few of the marketing, you know, things here and here, different trailers, little snippets of it.
And I think it's just ironic that that was actually the first boss asset made before everything.
The first monster because back in when we used to make random monsters and we'll find out how to use them.
And that was made for that game.
It was used in the original Peewee Two trailer.
Right.
It is the only incomplete, technically, but only from a balancing or was the last boss to finish in the entire path of Exile.
It sounds like it was like some sort of emotional demon that you had to battle there.
Like the legacy of the original idea and you had to finish it.
We had a moment with the monster game designers where we're like, oh my God, it's happening.
The Chimera is finally being finished.
Holy. This is like, yeah, we were effectively like we need to celebrate this boss finally being done.
It was like at the origin.
And now it's at this point where we're about to deploy early access, you know, not to say the end because the end is forever away.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's still the beginning of a journey in many ways.
But on that note of celebrating, like, how do you guys feel having now kind of for the first time, I feel really like laid bare kind of everything you have.
You're putting it out there and only being two weeks away from everyone playing it.
Well, it's always scary, you know, coming into a release.
And I think especially for, you know, there's like a bunch of people on the POE2 team who have, you know, like they have this is their first game that they're going to be releasing.
And that experience is something that, you know, like, yeah, like it's tough.
And honestly, I think that even we were feeling a little bit cocky actually about the fact because, you know, we release, you know, you know, content for POE1 all the time.
And I feel like we kind of felt like we knew what it took to get a game released.
But honestly, like POE2 was just a whole entirely different demon as far as getting things out.
Right. Like it's just way more difficult.
Like when you actually have to make everything like the whole fricking thing right, right from the ground up again.
It's like, wow, there's there's way more stuff there.
And like there's even things like like the passive tree where it's like, I feel like we underestimated what it would take to get something like that to an actual releasable state.
That was a huge amount of work, just like absolutely colossal to get it to, you know, to get that kind of stuff in shape.
Like it was it's just been crazy.
So, yeah, like obviously it's nerve wracking, you know, coming up to coming up to a release day.
But I think we do have something that players are going to really enjoy.
And, you know, like it's always comforting when, you know, I mean, we had a live event in L.A. recently, you know, people, you know, we got to the time loop and everyone's like, oh, man, we don't want to stop.
You know, so I think people are going to really enjoy it.
It's been a whole different experience for me here playing this time around as well, whereas before I was playing a very buggy kind of internal version of the game that was very experimental now playing, you know, almost what I'm going to be playing.
I heard you still managed to blow the count up the elevator with some kind of top back bug.
What was I going to mention?
Yeah, we have to just keep it that way.
I did send the Act 1 boss up an elevator with knockback.
It was intended mechanic.
It was pretty funny.
He was in his like big wolf form and kind of trapped in there.
So just barking at me through the through the wood.
So if you feel I'm sure there's a few things to work out of this next two weeks.
I hope the team can have a little bit of a rest for a day before they get back into it.
Yeah, it's been it's been a lot.
So you've done that pivot to the end game focus and got so much for us now to play around with in the beta.
And it seems like originally I was thinking, you know, we might be playing for a few weeks here and then, you know,
maybe going back over to some public one stuff.
It seems like you guys want us playing through Christmas.
That would certainly be good.
I mean, look, there's enough stuff there.
I think it will take people a long time to get through.
And I mean, obviously, it's also going to be the first time people playing through a completely fresh campaign as well.
I think that will take people a fair amount of time.
So, yeah, there's and then, of course, the end game as well to explore.
I mean, yeah, it should be pretty significant.
I mean, we've always wanted it to be that Path of Exile two leagues, you know, are going to be, you know, like how P1 leagues are.
We like you play them and you play them for like, you know, a reasonable amount of time.
And then, you know, sure, you get done with them eventually.
And then you've got the next content that comes out.
So, yeah, in order to be able to realize that you have to have enough of a base to make that happen.
Yeah, people definitely wondering like how invested they can get in the beta.
So I do want to ask a few questions kind of around that idea.
So is firstly, is there going to be wipes and resets and will there be something before launch as well?
So we are going to be having new like leagues effectively throughout the beta whenever we launch something significant because, you know, we want to make sure that all of the effectively that people are able to play through.
But that stuff will be merged into an early access league and effectively after we go into full release, that league will stick around.
Now, I can't promise that everything about your character will function exactly like how it did in that thing.
I imagine it would be a glorious kind of snapshot of all of the he's all broken stuff.
But effectively, we can contain all that stuff in the sort of early access league.
And then if you still want to play those characters, you know, like then you can go out ahead and do that.
But, you know, the action is always going to be in whatever the most recent league is.
And then, of course, after that point, there'll be a standard that everything goes into, which, you know, all our economic sins will forevermore be archived in the standard.
So, yeah, that's, you know, no doubt.
Well, it's nice that it's a not going to be affecting what will be the standard.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Also, people will be able to kind of get invested in their characters.
Yeah, absolutely. I mean, there's even something kind of cool about the idea of making something that will be like that little historical.
Absolutely. A little collectible.
Absolutely. And I'm sure there'll be some handful of legacy things that only exist in the early access league.
So, you know, I guess we'll have to see what gives a unique balance.
You talked about like the, you know, playing for a week or how long are we expecting?
We sort of remember and a lot of the, you know, a lot of the P1 players, we're thinking very differently to people who are obviously going to experience this as a new game, but it is a new game.
Right. You don't have all these predefined hyper refined builds to play to immediately, you know, go through things.
You don't have people coming in with like fully detailed 7 million line, but with build guides of exactly what to do with what items.
The discovery is going to be there.
The discovery takes time and the discovery is like honestly ultra fun for me.
I love it. Now those things will emerge after time.
Of course they do completely fine. But you should remember like there's a lot of game to play here to discover, to learn, learn about the world, the new narratives, the new world building, the new unique items, the ascenity classes, the massive passive tree, which is bigger than P1s.
The like, you know, end game systems, the bosses that it's it's not going to be this like, you know, even, you know, personally when I pay we one Lee comes out, for example, I play for like a month, sometimes a bit longer, sometimes a bit less.
It ultimately also depends largely what's going on here and how much I need to invest here.
So, you know, and there are other people who play for more like three and whatnot, but there's certainly going to be a much longer time period.
You can play this for while still discovering new stuff and not feel like you're finished.
You know what I mean? Now, of course, you see that subjective.
Everyone can pick their own point when they finish.
But if you want to see everything and do everything, you're going to be investing a lot more time, especially these first time rounds.
And then obviously with every league, there's more to discover.
But you get faster at doing all these parts over and over and over again.
You'll get more efficient over time. That's how the game works.
So, yeah, I would expect a lot of time to be sunk into this to fully explore it to start with like a lot, you know, not a week, not two weeks.
You're going to be going far, far longer than that if you want to see everything.
You know, it's up to you play at your own pace, see how you want to go, learn at your own pace.
That's the that's the beauty of a new game as well, which we haven't been able to experience the path of XR1, you know, or other games.
And for so long is actually discovering the entire world.
And there's some familiar mechanics at the end game and stuff like that, which is awesome for people.
But, yeah, I certainly want to really I'm very excited to see people discovering the new things and getting so excited about it.
I can tell you're amped for watching people go through that discovery process.
I may be even 100 percent.
I mean, I love sitting there in part of building as many as many of us do.
But I am very excited for that.
But as we're saying, the discovery process for a while, I think you were saying how much you were part spreadsheet.
I think I'm like I think I was saying I'm like maybe 60 percent spreadsheet, 40 percent discovery.
And there's my play archetype, you know, so I'm not without player profiles and Timmy Spikes and things like that.
We're both exalted characters.
The discovery part of me is ultra excited.
And I know, mind you, that's coming from someone who kind of knows all the content.
I'm still because there's something different about making it versus actually playing it live with the players, seeing them discover it, Unix being linked in chat and on Reddit and all that is just so, so, so cool.
We're going to get a massive dose of that.
And it is like genuinely exciting to see how people are going to think, you know, what's worth one chaos or what's with 10 chaos, what's worth a hundred.
If chaos is chaos, even the currency that people are arguing about this.
I'm pretty sure that one C spam and chat might turn into one E because I, you know, one exalt, you given that exalt is now I think it'll be chaos.
People probably have removal still be people don't appreciate it, by the way.
So when we say we're going to be getting multiple exalts in act one in in POE two, like we actually have increased that a lot.
It's not just like an idle, you know, like I can see exalts becoming the new kind of like chaos.
Yeah, I think I actually agree.
But yeah, we'll see.
But it's a new economy, right?
Like who knows the market will have to like they were already arguing about.
It's good fun.
So do you have some kind of like beta release roadmap for updates and things like that for people to look forward to it?
I mean, we certainly did have one six months ago.
But now that we're sort of getting to release it's like, oh my God, like, you know, look at it.
So, I mean, look, I don't think it'll be any less than six months.
And I think it could easily end up being more.
I certainly don't want to look twenty twenty five.
I think really want to to be fully released in twenty twenty five.
I don't really want to be spending more than a year.
That would be that would be pretty crazy.
But I mean, honestly, like we have to get all the content finished and all that sort of stuff.
You know, we always feel like we underestimate these things.
And of course, we have to learn what we need to learn.
We have to get the game to the point when it is really fun.
You know, we have to we have to make sure that like all of the things that, you know, we've got the difficulty right for the players, the economy right, like all the stuff.
I mean, there's a lot of things that we're going to sort out.
So I kind of have a feeling that the first few weeks at least are going to just be a scramble of like, you know, oh crap, someone like this crazy thing.
And we found this thing like, you know, the that's always scary, you know, because it's just when we had content to P.O.E.
one, it's like at least the kind of base of stuff that we have is kind of, you know, well tested and people know kind of what's going on with it.
But here it's just complete new world.
And we're the kind of game that has a lot of ability for players to do stuff that we wouldn't anticipate.
You know, we have the just the way support teams work and everything like that.
So I just there's certainly a lot of worry that like there's just going to be builds that like completely ridiculous that we just never anticipated.
Combining certain things in different ways, we don't expect, you know, with hundreds of support teams that can be like that.
So, you know, that's going to be an interesting one.
It will happen. Yeah, it is inevitable.
It is inevitable. Right.
Like there's nothing we can even do about it because you you need hundreds and thousands of hours of testing to be able to do that with what can only be done with hundreds of thousands of players.
And but that's also the magic of it all, which is awesome.
That's why I was asking you like, are you literally really doing 12 classes and 36 sentences like actually?
Yeah, absolutely. We have.
We have. We have. We know what we want to do.
It's a bit unhinged.
It is a bit, but, you know, we like a challenge.
I mean, you know, the studio that produces a passive skill tree like we do clearly has a bit of a glutton for punishment for the card to just like mix it in.
You totally put on six and then like, oh no, added more later in an expansion.
Yeah, I mean, maybe we could.
I mean, look, this is the plan.
This is the plan.
You know, I mean, like as you go through, as people go through early access, it's going to feel like it's just expansion content coming up pretty frequently.
I'm just because, you know, we have all the stuff that kind of got some of the way a lot of the way through.
So yeah, there's the stuff that I'm pretty sure like I really want to get the druid out like we announced it.
We've talked about it. It's a lot of fun.
You know, I'm keen to get that out there as soon as we can.
You know, the huntress we've talked to a bunch about as well is like those kinds of things I think will be, you know, we able to move towards those pretty quick.
But, you know, there's obviously more to do.
The other thing you mentioned talking roadmap like things is we've always been, you know, it's hard to predict because a lot of what will happen is and what we leave space for is reacting to what the players want.
And so if you plan everything for so long, you're going to have very, very, very slow reaction times to fixing, you know, or adding certain content with them.
You know, maybe the issue is I are the campaign needs more of this or this class needs more of this or something.
So if you're planning, then you're going to be delivering on what they want solved like a year down the line or even longer.
And where we like to remain very, very dynamic and like, you know, you want to be able to fix that stuff like, oh, well, this is the main problem.
Like, sure, obviously, you need more than a week sometimes, most of the time.
But we want it generally to be that the next releases, expansions, updates, whatever can alleviate as many of those problems as possible.
So, yeah, you try not to get too strict with the planning is generally been our philosophy because especially when it comes to actually having the light service product out, because that is very, very important.
Otherwise, you're you're never going to seem like you're doing what people want.
And what are you doing if not that?
So that actually is good point.
I was going to ask, what do you folks, what does the team want out of the beta?
Because obviously it's like a good way to market the game, but it's also, you know, key to shaping the game in the future.
Like the actual beta, it's not just early access.
I think one of the most important things, I think it's going to be really good for the development team to get back into a live mindset and like get it back into the idea of like everything we make is shipping.
People are seeing this.
Like, you know, like actually getting back to that and like, yeah, like being able to sort of see directly like, OK, we make something that goes in the game.
People like it, don't like it, like that kind of stuff.
Like that really like that has been our studio for like most of its lifetime.
Obviously, we know before we released P1, it wasn't.
But after that point, I mean, we are a company like we are a company that likes to think that we can do live service better than anyone else.
Like that is our goal.
And so like getting back into that again, you know, for the entire for everyone in the studio, so everyone's working on things that are going to be releasing within, you know, certainly in less time than, you know, than three months away.
Is it going to be really, really good for us again?
I look forward to just being able to do that because these these long term, like really long term things like that span over years.
So you go so long without proper feedback, like stuff kind of gets made and then like, you know, it's not really in a real game.
And so it doesn't probably lose perspective and you absolutely lose perspective on the stuff.
So I think that that's just going to be a really great to get back to that again.
Honestly, as you said, it is early access.
It is a beta period.
And I'd say, you know, personally speaking, the thing that and we mentioned it briefly about the character balance and the builds that are broken and all that.
That's obviously pretty useful to me.
Right.
Plus, we have other systems in there like, you know, the checkpointing system, right.
You have to kill the boss in one life.
You know, these are things we haven't mass tested.
And obviously other games have and they work and that's awesome.
There are other things like, you know, the end game system is a little bit less forgiving and that if you die, you fail the map.
Right.
These things are things that we obviously need to test and iterate on in the future by adjusting the difficulty and stuff like that.
And you especially as you get towards this point of, you know, the end game.
Okay. Act one has been tested like crazy.
Yeah. Right.
And you get less and less testing as it goes on because you get less people.
They've just been around for less time.
And so, yeah, it's going to be a huge amount of iteration and feedback and from the players and us just, you know, reevaluating all the stuff.
And the thing is, we're always dynamic about that stuff.
Like, we'll just change things if it's wrong, we'll redesign it, we'll come up with a new way.
Jonathan's a firm believer of if A doesn't work and B doesn't work, then we'll find C, we'll find option C, we'll find option D and we'll keep changing things and we'll make it work.
So, yeah, it's going to be a lot of that iteration on our design decisions, how forgiving, because like the game is pretty hard.
You know, it can be pretty hard.
And so when you're on that fine line of like, you know, things are difficult, you know, it's not too easy to know if you've tilted one way or the other.
So, you know, finding what everyone agrees should be the common corrective difficulty is something that I will obviously be paying very, very, very close attention to.
It's a pretty hard thing to nail down when you are making the game.
And so you've we've seen that a lot where you folks have been pretty willing to change and then re-change and re-change again some of the core features like flasks and the waypointing system and portals.
And you're keeping that kind of mindset going into the beta then.
Of course. I mean, look, we're always willing to change stuff.
Like that flask thing, like the most recent change to that was like ultra recent.
Yeah.
Like, I don't have we even had like a closed beta of that yet?
No.
I think we haven't yet.
But I mean, I think it's way better than it was.
Like it's the things things have improved a lot.
And honestly, like that's one of those things we've been wanting to do something to sort out flasks for ages.
Yeah.
And it really came about because when actually looking at what new players were having trouble with when they were playing flask piano was actually like even from the very beginning of the game actually ended up being one of those things that like people just had problems.
Just the manual dexterity required to like hit all your different flask keys and then like know like you have to know when one of your flasks run out.
So you can move to the next one and like various things like that.
Like all that stuff actually was like just a weirdly large amount of mechanical complexity right from the very beginning.
And then even at end game, I don't think it was really that satisfying either because you ended up with like, you know, just like having to press all these buttons all the time.
And obviously, it's all utility flasks that people are using at end game.
And then we kind of tried to band-aid this in Peewee 1 with the, you know, some of the flask automation stuff that was out there.
But there was still this idea that you're still more powerful if you don't automate.
So therefore, you know, like it's like, you know, there's that trade off there.
So you're just more powerful if you get mage blood.
Sure, sure.
I mean, it's all automated and you're very powerful.
But, you know, so the point is effectively that the charm stuff that we're doing effectively means that you no longer the game is making that decision of like, you know, that stuff will be automated.
You no longer have to do that like crazy flask piano to get the best, you know, the best every character.
And I think that is definitely a step in the right direction.
And the other thing as well as it actually makes the crafting more meaningful, I think, on the flasks, because when you've got like five slots, then like the individual mods and the individual stuff like seems to tend to not matter as much.
I mean, obviously, you know, people want instant recovery and things like that.
But, you know, like the but like now it's like the actual it's much more meaningful, like on your life flask, the choice between do I want instant or do I want way more like life like that kind of stuff actually can be a lot more meaningful once you've only got one.
So, yeah, I think I think it is a lot better personally.
You have we'll jump ahead to floss since we're on the topic.
You have locked in effectively the fact that there's a amount of floss there now.
So there's always going to be a amount of floss.
And how does that how does that tie into your design for manner?
And are we always going to be using a lot or if we solve another way?
What does it do?
You can absolutely solve another way and then you'll just have a flat slot that isn't doing anything for sure.
But I think kind of has to work that way because we really don't want.
Yeah, but like once you sort of start getting to changing that around, I feel like the system sort of starts to break with regard to like, you know, the feeling of like I know where manner is I know my health is like that kind of stuff.
That being said, you know, we've always got uniques and stuff like that.
I believe there's already.
Yeah, there is a unique that allows you to equip to floss.
But the thing is then that's a build choice that you're making.
So it's a little bit different and that's fine.
But, you know, I think the system as it works now just a lot easier.
So it does sound like on the manner side of things then that there are going to be multiple angles of solving manner.
Of course, of course.
We've got leech edition number four hundred and seventy five.
It works and we finally got it right this time.
You know, the idea I think it works.
I think it's good.
So I think that leech will be more common.
I'm going to have to like crack out the leech diagram.
Yeah, yeah.
Buckets and things like I was saying, I think I think that leech might be no, I think I was going to say leech is one of the topics in the studio that has wasted the most design of time of anything in the industry.
But I actually don't think it's that.
I think the actual worst offender is what stats should decks give you?
I think that that is like that one has wasted so there's so many arguments about that.
I feel like that one's never come to the fore.
Like we know about each one.
But no one is happy about giving accuracy, but no one has a better idea than what accuracy that it can give.
And everyone's going to come up with like and chat a bit.
I bet they'll be like saying, oh, you know, I can give this or this whatever.
But there's like, yes, seriously, there's been endless arguments about that topic.
It's like it's outrageous.
Yeah.
Hmm.
You've got me thinking about it now.
Yeah.
I mean, speed would be good, but then it's probably too much.
Something like decks.
You should start deck stacking.
We can get all the designers down here right now.
I know.
We'll just have it out again.
The longest Q&A of all time.
It's already going to be that.
Sometimes you're just like, we start the day, you're like, here are the problems we need to solve.
And then you're like, what about accuracy on decks comes up again.
It's 3 p.m. and we're still discussing dexterity.
Yeah.
So I go home, just make it accuracy.
Exactly.
That is literally how it comes back to accuracy every time.
This is okay.
Yeah.
Rewinding a little bit.
We can't forget our roots with Path of Exile 1, of course.
So for the POE1 enjoyers, what is the plan for POE1 during the course of this beta?
Is there going to be leagues launching?
Is it on the back burner?
Yeah.
There absolutely will be leagues launching.
Now, I don't know the exact date, but the plan is kind of late February.
But I mean, look, we'll see what happens.
I will admit that unfortunately we did have to steal a few POE1 resources just towards the end here,
which has kind of been a bit unfortunate.
I really wish we didn't have to.
But yeah, as I said, we kind of underestimated some of the stuff.
But everyone is going to be going back to POE1 again for the February League.
And we're going to make sure that we can do that.
One of the things that was a big problem for our studio when we had a long term project and a short term project
is that you've always had that thing of like you always want to work on the short term thing.
So now that we've got two short term things coming up, actually it's going to be a bit easier to prioritize in some respects.
Because it's like all that stuff is then coming up soon.
But we'll see. We'll see how it goes.
But yeah, we need to get that POE1 expansion out next.
Obviously, I just want to always make it clear that the reason why things can't be so planned out is again, we're just releasing this game.
Obviously, we pivoted to end game and then that needed more resources.
And then of course, combined with the fact that things obviously change.
There are unpredictable things in the environment we can't necessarily guarantee.
And then of course, you have Christmas coming up and all of that.
There's so many variables to consider.
But we also don't know how much time is going to be invested necessarily or need to be invested into live operations for post release.
How many problems are going to go wrong?
How many builds are there? How many of the uniques are broken?
And where do all these resources go?
There are like just millions of variables here to consider.
And so it can get very, very difficult, especially after this time.
But once you release, you have a grace period, so to speak, where we're more like a period of extreme amounts of fire, where we're putting out fires everywhere.
We have a period where we're fixing everything, you get everything stable, and then we're going to be like, all right, let's recalibrate, figure everything out.
And what is our plans? And then establish all of that based also on the feedback we get from that period where everything's on fire.
Not to make it sound like it's going to be bad, but that is the inevitability is that there's always problems.
Hopefully it appears good from a player perspective, but there's always going to be like, oh my God, people found us.
We don't have to see all the fires.
Ideally, the best thing is when we're able to fix some kind of exploit before people even hear about it.
And when I say exploit, I'm just talking about some broken thing.
We obviously normally have to worry about the whole mid-league nerf concept, but it's like if you can deal with something within an hour or two of it happening,
then it's like you're kind of OK because no one had a chance to swap their build over to it or whatever.
But we're going to have to be really on the ball for POE 2 just because there's so many things that are new.
Wow. I mean, look, we have several bosses with several elevators.
How many of them can be pushed up the elevator?
You know what I mean?
When I say a fire, I'm talking about bosses getting pushed up elevators.
That's not OK.
I am liking my mercenary flashbang knockback is very fun.
Yeah, you need to look into that, by the way.
I feel like you're going to nerf my build.
Stay away from my grenade.
He's finding fires already.
These are the fun things.
Discovering that stuff can be very fun for the players.
It's just internally, it's like, oh no, what are we doing?
It can get a little bit panicky after release, you know, and there's lots of things going on.
You're like, oh, geez, what do I sell first?
But obviously, you know, it's the same as POE 1.
We're good at it at this point.
You are going to be torturing us with like releasing beta stuff at the same time as POE 1 league launches.
Yeah, the plan is to keep them separated a bit from each other so that you get a chance to play.
Don't make me choose.
So we saw a cinematic, to put it lightly.
It was pretty, that was quite epic.
And I know has been cooking for quite some time.
And that was pretty exciting.
But we've also seen just a lot of story stuff happening in a much higher level than previously now.
So you're stepping up your storytelling game here a bit.
Yeah, so we really wanted to make sure that the storytelling in POE 2 is much better than what it was in POE 1.
Like, you know, there's a lot more kind of, I guess, like that kind of like stuff with the introductions to boss fights and the outros and things like that.
Like all that stuff, we've just got a lot more storytelling going in.
All of those things.
We do have the intro cut scene.
There's also can kind of like light, like between the acts, these kind of like more kind of motion graphic type cut scenes just kind of establish things.
And there might be some more surprises later on in the game as well.
Not in early access, unfortunately.
Later on that we can see as well.
But ultimately, we just want to make sure that like I think a lot of people who got through the POE 1 story had no idea what was happening by the end.
And so effectively want to make sure that is not the case this time around, that people really are able to absorb things.
But one thing I will say, though, is that it's ultra important to us that we don't break the feeling that like when you're playing a second time that it like that it feels like we don't want to feel annoying the second time.
We were talking about this this morning.
Yeah, yeah.
Don't take the control out of the players hands.
Exactly.
So yeah, I'm a personally a believer of the fact that if you just change when you change the camera position for a cut scene, immediately it feels way more annoying.
Like, because this just hold this whole thing like like if you click on an NBC and like the camera changes position, like, sure, when you're playing through the campaign the first time, that kind of thing is like, you know, like that can be cool.
But then the if you're like you're playing through the second, third, fourth, fifth time, you want to try to go to the NBC and click, click, click, click and just get past without feeling like you've had to sort of worry about anything.
So yeah, like effectively we want to make sure that it's still that we still have that, you know, because ultimately, you know, we're a game you expect people to play through many times.
So ideally we can kind of deliver both the situation where the first time you play through it, it feels like an amazing story that you're getting that you're taking seriously that you're understanding that you know there's like all those sort of touch points and, you know, little, little, you know, things just all through while also maintaining the fact that if you know what you're doing, it's like you don't have to go talk to some quest giver just to get a quest like you could just go do the thing, you know, without having to talk to someone about it first.
So, you know, that kind of stuff is really important just to make the, you know, that that stuff work well when you when you know what you're doing.
You said something this morning that stuck with me where you said like Path of Exile is a game where the player's meta knowledge is allowed and encouraged.
Absolutely. Absolutely. So you're allowed to cheat this quest.
Effectively, yes. Effectively, there's what the character knows and there's what the player knows and in our game what the player knows is needs to be sufficient as far as like being able to progress the storyline.
If you can, you're not, you don't want to have it so you just talk to NBC just to find out something you already knew as a player.
Yeah, like if you know you kill this boss, you get the next area's waypoint. So you just like kill it log in.
I love doing that. Meta knowledge.
So you explained to me the other day the kind of the context for the beast and how that leads into the cutscene in the beginning of POE 2 from POE 1 and that I think helped put it in a lot more perspective for me and made me appreciate and understand what's going on in the story.
Yeah, so effectively what you're seeing in the opening cutscene is effectively a new seed of a beast that is going to be growing.
Now in POE 1, the beast was killed and then what happened in response to that is a bunch of all the gods in the world were able to effectively rise again.
And you killed a bunch of them, but there are more in the world and effectively, we don't want to spoil too much about the storyline overall, but effectively obviously someone here, the Count is wanting to harness the power of the beast once again.
And then we have the mysterious figure there who is saying, no, don't do this. This always turns out badly.
There was a comment in chat that I loved that was like, stop opening Eldritch boxes.
Exactly.
Why do people keep doing this?
Yeah, I would.
If someone handed you a mysterious orb, wouldn't you press the button?
I mean, exactly.
I mean, I'm going to try, but who knows how many hours it's going to take me.
Indeed.
So we had a fun moment earlier where you were watching it and you were like, oh, we really need to need to rename that passive because he's a Karui and it's a wolf.
It's called Great Wolf's Howl.
Great Wolf's Howl.
So he went up to Isomite history.
I started telling him.
I stomped out of the room.
I was like, we need to rename that notable. He's Karui.
And then I was kindly reminded that actually he was an orphan and was adopted by Isomite and raised.
And so, yes, there is a mixture of Karui and Isomite background.
And I was like, it works.
You're wrong.
Fair enough. I walked back in here all sad and whatever.
My bad.
It's fine.
The name is good.
He looked so chastised when he came back in.
But that just like points to the fact that I feel like you're doing a lot more with the characters here.
You even mentioned that ascendancy stuff is going to have an impact story wise.
That's wild.
We just think a lot about this kind of stuff.
So the acolyte of, I always get this name wrong, the acolyte of, is it Chayula?
Chayula.
Chayula. I always say this wrong.
So the acolyte of Chayula, for example.
So we have this sort of storyline with the origins of the monks where there's like an order of monks who worship a thing they call the dreamer.
And the dreamer is actually Chayula.
So they don't know this.
They're worshiping a breach demon.
So the acolyte of Chayula is effectively you embracing the fact that I'm worshiping a breach demon.
I'm just going to go all the way.
I'm in too deep now.
Exactly.
We're just going to do it.
So yeah, there's a lot of thinking like that that goes into these things.
What is the history of these people?
Because I think a lot of that stuff inspires interesting mechanics as well.
So for example, on that one, you've got that into the breach skill, which kind of means you're always in a breach all the time.
You can see the like things going on.
That stuff is I think there's a lot of cool inspiration there.
So coming up with that storyline stuff for that stuff, I think just a couple of the little things that I think is cool as well.
And hopefully people will notice and pay attention to.
So there's one of the bosses that was shown as uses a lot of time or chronomancy.
And interestingly, if you are a sorceress and you ascend to chronomancer and you then go to fight that boss, if you, for example, try to use time freeze, the boss is like, yeah, that doesn't work on me.
And there's a dialogue line.
And if you cast temporal chains on them, he's like, you know, just puts it back on you.
And it's like, yeah.
And so there's interesting things like that.
And it doesn't like change things on a grand scale, right?
It doesn't make a certain class not viable or anything like that.
But there's this interesting little quirks and quips everywhere.
Different bosses have different intro lines, depending on what class you're playing.
They have different skill lines sometimes, depending on what class you're playing.
Yeah, we've got different dialogue all through the campaign for different classes like the sorceress was obviously from the Marraketh.
When she goes back to the Marraketh, there's kind of a little backstory there about how she was banished originally.
So, you know, she needs to find a way to be, she needs to be accepted back into the culture again.
You know, like we've got things like, you know, the character we talked about earlier.
So the warrior, you know, was an orphan.
You know, he he was brought up by actually one of the NPCs in Act One Town.
So obviously there's a whole different dialogue there because he's effectively has adopted son.
You know, we've got things like that.
There's a lot of thought that's gone into, you know, trying to make it feel like all these character classes have some level of involvement with the world, you know, that didn't just come into existence the moment that you.
There's other little things.
So like more on the narrative side of you, obviously, we saw the world map.
You have the icons that show different things that are in each act, like all the things you want to explore.
So find and yeah, awesome.
But each of them also has a little bit of a kind of little bit of text on them as well.
And like, for example, the there's one in one of the first areas in the game that's just like a camp of iron count guards.
And, you know, we showed it in a trailer when the when the Ranger class trailer we did, you know, whenever it was, you saw the Ranger shoot some of the kill some of the people.
They were trying to like hurt a child, you know, and the child was just trying to get some food and the Ranger just like snipes them with arrows and kills them ruthlessly.
And so you read this thing and you're like, you know, you hear whispers of an iron count, you know, scouting party that was slain by a rogue archer or something like that.
So you get these little things where we like connecting a lot of little dots and even that you absorb a little bit of interesting little information.
You've got other things, for example, when you enter an area, it not only says the name at the top now, it has almost a subtitle text that's giving you a little bit a little bit of history.
These little things like somehow make the world building feel so much better.
And when you approach certain landmark rooms and you walk into them, you'll get a banner at the top as well, which says what it is and gives again a little bit of a thing and all these little micro narrative delivery mechanisms like make you feel way more immersed in the world and way more aware of what's going on.
And way more connected to your character, way more connected to the bosses, to the NPCs.
It's yeah, there's a lot we're doing now that we certainly never did before.
We didn't even think of before.
Yeah, it's it's I like that a lot because like as an action RPG gamer, I don't really care too much about plot, but I do want a really cool world to be blowing monsters up in basically.
That's like I want characters to be cool, I want the baddies to be cool and I want like the things happening around me that like in, you know, build out a bit of that story without me having to stop killing stuff.
Yeah.
And it sounds like there's more of that going on as well.
Which is great.
The baddies being cool.
I mean, that's how we almost designed an ascendancy class in here just before when we were watching that trailer earlier.
So what you were saying a shadow, you came up with a shadow ascendancy.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, internally, we had some developers watching the trailer yesterday getting excited about it.
And then I was like, I want to play that.
I want to play that character.
I want to be that character.
That's awesome.
That like kind of Vaal, Thormiturge type character.
And so like, cool.
All of a sudden, it's like, we should make that a class.
And then we had another guy like suggest it should be a shadow.
And so now I'm like, oh, yeah, we're definitely come on.
We have to do a Vaal, Thormiturge shadow ascendancy.
Like, that's gonna be cool.
You can do awesome things now even.
I know it's hard to say because you hide it under all the armor, but you can do things like, you know, with our character classes, just due to the upgrades and models where all of a sudden now the character can have tattoos added to them and stuff like that is completely feasible in the future.
And like, I would I want to do a lot more of that stuff.
And stuff like for the there's little things that for the Warbringer, I think was the class name on the warrior.
When you take that ancestral totem node, all your totems now have like an extra blue glow to them kind of like they're enhanced by this ancestral magic.
And what we also want to do is has add tattoos as well that like glow blue when you're using certain skills and all that.
So heaps of little things that again connects all the culture and all that stuff together and make you feel like, you know, it's believable as opposed and this is a character as opposed to this is just a mechanic and you know.
Makes picking an ascendancy more epic.
I know that there was a part in the trailer that was like not fully finished where you ascend and it doesn't really do anything, but I know you want it to be like a cool moment where some power goes in here.
Yeah, absolutely. We just hadn't finished the VFX yet.
Even the another one, the blood mage. When you like, you know, play the blood mage and now you can edit of surge on your character whenever you cast spells, you're getting like almost blood bending kind of vibe going on and like drawing it from their veins and sending a fireball.
It's cool. Yeah.
Yeah, you can have like the tattoos get tattooed on them as they as they ascend and things like that.
I mean, that just makes taking a sentence a way more cool, which is already I think I almost feel like a sentence is more important than the classes for players kind of like feeling the vibe of what they want to do with their character for sure.
Because I mean, the classes are pretty open. You can play whatever skills whatever weapon show you're on a passive tree at a start point.
But you know, by high level, you kind of go wherever you want to go using jewels, especially getting off class stuff. You can kind of be whatever you want with the base class.
So eventually, yeah, the ascendancy is what becomes more of that important identifying feature, because that's what you have actually chosen that makes you distinct that another different class wouldn't be able to actually have.
So yeah, yeah. So you want to make that super, super cool.
And on that note, I was definitely confused. I know people are definitely confused and a little worried about ascendancy and what's happening with that.
And people were like watching the like the second trial and being like, oh, what if I don't like this?
Oh, it's just another lab again. But I want you to like lay it out as like simply as possible.
Like how do you ascend? Yeah.
Yeah. So effectively, in the full game, there's going to be three ascendancy trials for early access.
There's two. And effectively, you can use any of those ascendancy trials to be able to do your ascension.
You choose. You choose which one.
And effectively, if you as you get to high level, like high level keys for those trials, that will unlock more points.
Like if you do it at certain level break points, that will allow you to get more points for those classes.
So if you want to just play the entire just just only the trial of the chaos god with, you know, to get all your points, then you can just decide to do that.
Just play at a higher and higher levels and get more points as you go through.
You know, if you want to do a mix, that's fine, too.
Personally, I think people want to try out all the different content.
I mean, you might think that you but even within the trials, there's there's choices, right?
Like I know that there's always contention around traps.
But because in the trial, the second is you can choose which rooms you want to go to.
If you don't want to deal with traps, you just don't pick those rooms, right?
Like you don't go to the rooms, you can just go to other things.
The combat ones.
And that's fine, too. So effectively, it's like you always get to choose what you're doing there.
Like it's funny because I know traps are so contentious, but also there are other people who just enjoy that stuff.
So, you know, you want to have something for all those people to.
There's a path of exile, divisive content, but lots of choice.
And you can choose what to do and what not to do.
And then we're embracing that here now.
And that's clearly leaning into that now.
You have you have I mean, such a competitive advantage in that you have so much content.
And even with P2, that's still going to be the case.
So you can lean into that, like making content that is spicier but divisive.
And now you're like separating trees and having these things be a little able to be focused on a lot more.
And you're doing that with the trials with your sentences.
And you can like you can kind of do all of them and drip feed yourself smaller.
And there's also stuff that you're going to be getting from those like specific rewards and everything that might incentivize you to do that.
But of course, on the other hand, if you don't want to do that content, we have open, full open trade, right?
You can just trade for the rewards and that's fine, too.
So, you know, like that's always part of it.
Yes, like the rewards there, for example, like jewels drop throughout the world.
But if you want to get more jewels, you go and run sanctum.
Now, if you want to get the radius jewels, you do sanctum.
I can't.
Trial of the second.
So for anyone who isn't a Path of Exile 1 player, this is effectively a sequel to Sanctum League that we did in Path of Exile 1.
So it's mechanically very similar.
But it's obviously, you know, America, you know, like America trial now.
And, you know, we've changed a lot of things about it have changed and like the content is new.
But it is effectively the same overall mechanic, you know, in terms of that sort of rogue like mechanic that we have.
The same with the other one. You have Ultimatum in POE 1 being the theme.
And of course, now it's redesigned and it's evolved into Trial of Chaos.
So, yeah, a lot of people in chat would have been spamming Ultimatum.
And for those who haven't played, would probably be like, I don't understand.
Effectively, the Trial of Chaos is a sequel to Ultimatum, which is...
And we just have to get used to the new names, which is very hard.
But yeah, anyway, the point being, of course, in Vaal Orbs drop in the world as well.
And if you want a larger dose of Vaal Orbs and you know, you don't want to trade, go feel free to run some Ultimatums.
Thing is, because they're all item generated keys as well, it's not like you have to do it right then and there.
You can trade the keys away. At any point, you can also buy more keys if you want to farm more of that thing.
And if you just want to do it later, just stockpile a bunch of them, run them all at your leisure.
You know what I mean? It's like you have the freedom.
So I don't know if they are itemized, tradable, as is a lot in Path of Exile tradition, but...
Well, as is everything, right? The only thing you can't trade is gold.
So we're like the exact opposite of most games, where it's like the gold is freely tradable and the items get locked.
We're like the gold is the only thing you can't trade and every other item is free and open.
Yeah, and that's because you've made gold be this way to be like, you're playing the game so you have access to this.
And you don't want to trade that away.
Effectively.
So on the ascendancies and the trials, how hard do you foresee getting your ascendancy to be while leveling?
Do you expect people to fail out and attempt these things multiple times? And what does that look like if you do?
Well, I failed the first time I did the trial.
It is important to know that that first itemized key is a quest key.
And we have special rules around it that if you do fail, you can just repeat it, right?
You changed that recently because that was something that I didn't actually realize you'd changed.
I guess it was a little bit too harsh to require to get another one.
Yeah, you weren't the only one failing it.
But yeah, so pretty much you get to reattempt it.
And for something like Ultimatum, just to immediately start thinking of VXploit, I can just do three of the waves, then intentionally fail and then repeat them.
Well, we've thought of that. Don't worry. You can't.
But yeah, the first ones are repeatable.
You're not going to be like, what the heck, now I have to just play to the whims of random generation to ascend?
It is pretty hard, though. I definitely don't think you'll do it on your first attempt.
I did, not to brag. I did pass on. I was clenched, though.
Yeah, OK. Yeah, especially that boss fight.
I was watching him do the boss fight from afar.
You came by right as I was doing the boss fight.
But you had some kind of powerful boons there, to be perfectly honest.
I got 60% move speed. That was part of my strategic choice.
I was watching you from... How is he so fast?
This isn't the Pee-wee 2 slide.
I was like, what, with Dodger, I was going across half the arena?
This game is supposed to be slow.
It was good fun. I quite liked it.
I mostly like Sanctum. I don't want to do it all the time, but I did quite like the Trial of Sakama,
knowing that there's other choices, so I can de-ultimate them instead or something like that.
That's fun, 100%.
So you've got these two roguelike dungeons that are going into the beta that launch, but they're done very differently.
One's got the honor system, which is like a separate health, but it's based on and scaled by your health,
which I noted is quite interesting.
And your defenses now, it can be fully mitigated and everything.
Yeah, so fully scaled by your character. You go in in a tanky character, you'll be tanky in the dungeon, which is really cool.
And then with Ultimatum, and just because people will ask, in Ultimatum there aren't any traps.
Yes. No traps in Ultimatum and no honor system in Ultimatum.
If you just want more of a pure combat experience, then that's your choice.
And then there's going to be a third one as well, which is a secret for now.
So once Act 4 goes on, then we'll have a third trial.
So people sort of broadly know that the Kurui are in Act 4, so it's a question of how would the Kurui ascend, is the question.
Yes, and if there's any other things that have been called trials associated with the Kurui at some point in the past.
How likely that is to be related.
I'm just thinking now, we were just thinking of the Vile Thormiturge class before, and I'm already thinking,
Oh, it'd be so cool if you ascend in Ultimatum.
We want the Trialmaster to say different lines to you because you're like choosing the way of the Vile.
I can't stop thinking about all this stuff.
I did hear a few of his lines in some of the gameplay Jontham was showing me.
I love that he's back, the Trialmaster.
He's cool.
A little salty sometimes that you're taking this power, it seems.
So we have the unique rewards from each of them.
Like you said, the jewels are global, but there are unique jewels, and then there are unique socketables from the other one.
And is there something planned to be unique from the final third trial that will be added later?
Of course.
Yes, there is already.
I know what they are. I'm not going to say it, don't worry.
Keep some secrets, fine then.
Again, I value the discovery.
If I accidentally say it, it is certainly by mistake.
But yes, don't worry.
That Vile Orbs from the Ultimatum in particular, they seem like they're a lot more important, a lot more powerful.
I certainly think that some of the stuff is a lot better with how they work.
One of the things that we wanted to change was that implicit on items are truly implicit.
You can't get rid of them, they stay there.
So that means that when you do a Vile Orb, the mod that you get there now is in addition to whatever implicit already had, which is obviously good.
And then the next one being that you can get plus one socket above the normal limit, which is also kind of powerful.
Especially with the soul cores.
In the Trial of Chaos, you get soul cores that you can't get from anywhere else.
And those effectively are mods that are typically a bit beyond what you would normally get on regular items.
Whereas runes, which kind of drop everywhere, those ones are just kind of normal everyday mods that you would expect to find on any kind of item.
Resists and things like that.
Yes, just resists and damage and that kind of stuff.
So effectively the soul cores is kind of the more end-gamey socketables that you might want to be using.
And obviously being able to get plus one socket.
It's something that everyone will want.
But on the other hand, there is that risk of just breaking your item.
So that's the deadly gamble you have as your final crafting step there.
Vile Orbs are more forgiving though.
They are, yes.
If you think about, we talked about enchantment.
So some slots you might value the enchantment over a rune or a socket slot.
And I think that's probably, especially towards end-game, I'd say that's probably going to tilt that way.
Because maybe a soul core contests with it.
But the whole point is that there's choice there involved.
So there's enchantment, we just talked about the socket.
There's obviously always the case of doing nothing, which happens.
But for just say regular rare items, it will reroll one to three modifiers at random.
Effectively do a Chaos Orb on one to three modifiers, not all six.
And as much as that can often be a downside, because if you're using it on a very good item, obviously it's going to take away the good ones.
But if you're using it on a mid item, you can actually turn it very good.
I've had this happen, when I've been playing, I've got like, life, defense, defense, double res, and something else that I don't want.
And I'm like, I'll just start vialing everything because why not?
I've got my Vile Orbs and I vial it and it rerolls that bottom mod into a tri-res.
And then I got a tri-res, double defense, life helmet and I was like, you're awesome.
So even that, which can often be perceived as a bad outcome now, isn't going to completely brick your item.
For example, if you have a weapon, you've got your three damage mods and you've got some bad suffixes, it could even be an option.
Or hopefully it doesn't just remove all three damage mods.
Whereas before, if it bricked it, it often was almost always a brick.
That item is now dead.
Tell me about a new unique result, which I don't know if you want to spoil or not.
100%. It's cool. It's so cool.
I'm surprised you even got that one past Rishi, honestly.
I mean, he got it made. We discussed it.
I agree. I messaged it to him thinking he'll be like, no way, this is unacceptable.
He was there for it.
It didn't turn into a dexterity chat.
What it effectively does is it just takes the mod values and it goes up to, I can't remember exactly the values,
but let's just say it changes all the values to between 0.8 and 1.2 of what they were multiplied.
But it doesn't care about the minimum and maximums.
So for example, if you had a thousand life calms heart, you can use this to get, again, this is me assuming it's 20% variance,
because I can't remember what we balanced it to, but you'll be able to get a 1200 life calms heart, for example.
Now that's obviously giving up the enchantment and a socket.
Just think about sockets on calms heart. I can't remember what we did, but whatever.
I think you can actually do that, which is interesting.
But ultimately it's like, yeah, now I'm choosing, do I want the enchantment?
Do I want an extra 100 something 200 life, whatever that ends up being?
Or do I want the socket?
So it's quite an interesting choice and adds an extra access of corruption to unique items that is, I think.
Corrupted divining of uniques.
Yeah, effectively, yeah, it's divining them, but with higher maximums and lower minimums.
Surely there's going to be some broken things like max res or something like that.
I mean, we'll guess we'll find out.
Cross that bridge when it comes to it.
Yeah, it's fine.
So that was all just talking about the trials, how you actually get your ascendancies,
what about the actual ascendancies themselves?
How are they cooking?
Well, they're fun. They're cool.
We certainly try to get what we've tried to do is for the class, we've tried to have one that's a bit more out there.
Something that isn't just, you know, like if you think even about in Pee Wee Wan, you've got the duelist.
You can go like champion or slayer or holy words.
I don't remember, but you know the drill.
And the gladiator.
And the problem is like, OK, they're all just about like hitting stuff with weapons and they haven't.
There's nothing really out there. Sure, they all sound cool.
Don't get me wrong, and they can be cool.
And they do have differences, but there's nothing that's like kind of crazy.
So all of a sudden now when you're like, you know, sorceress, you're using all your elemental skills.
And now you can just like go into this thing that can stop time.
You know, it's a little bit more crazy.
And you've got the mercenary and you can turn into a gemling legionnaire and effectively fuse gems into your flesh to like, you know, mutate yourself.
You know, it's like not just talking about crossbows and projectiles over and over and over and over again.
It's like doing kind of whack stuff.
So I really like that. That's awesome.
And we're going to make sure every single class has one thing that is like definitely out there.
And then one thing that's, you know, more predictable, more to the expectation of the trope, you know, for example, the dead eye to the ranger.
And but yeah, lots and lots of cool interactions, just cool and playing with different mechanics.
And we've tried to make them like, for example, none of them call out a weapon, right?
None of them. So you we're trying to make sure that they're broad enough to be that you might be a ranger going a dead eye, but playing a caster, right?
Playing spells, like keeping all of that open, that flexibility, that kind of crazy, you know, for the Johnny players, as we call it out there,
who want to just completely experiment and figure out, you know, the most broken weird stuff, you know, and you get things with that when you still like, OK, OK, I'm a ranger.
And I'm using a quill rain and one weapon set specked into a bunch of prod speed attack speed.
And in my second weapon set, I'm using a spell caster staff with a bunch of projectile stuff.
And I'm invested into more spell damage side.
And you've got a whack tree and all of a sudden now you're this like dead eye archer spell caster mage hybrid doing all kinds of wacky stuff or like even or let's say the same build and experimenting with a bunch of triggers.
And so you're using your bow as a quill rain as a higher tax speed delivery mechanism for, you know, laying down a bunch of either CCs or slows or building up crowd controls.
And then you're using the caster stuff and like you get some pretty out there things going on.
And the important thing is it's not like just like benefiting only arrows or only bow attacks or anything like that.
It's broad and now, you know, opens up the world to what you can do and same like the gemling legionnaire on the mercenary is entirely just about gem slot skills, support zero.
There's no you don't have to be anything. You can be literally whatever build you want.
And yeah, so that that's embracing that making sure people still even though we have all these classes you are embracing that path of Excel, you can do anything fantasy that we want people to be able to do.
And if you don't want to go with the trope perfectly fine, you'll still be powerful.
It sounds like you're really trying to avoid that thing that we've had a couple times in POE one where like a certain niche is relegated to on ascendancy.
Like that's the only way to go for it.
It sounds like it's not going to be the case here.
Well, if we're doing our job right that yeah.
And with so many of the sentences as well.
Got a lot of choices.
Originally, the plan was to like have all of the POE one ascendancies available and it was some sort of weird split campaign stuff and all that.
I don't really know at this point.
It's a bit confusing.
It's you mentioned that either.
So it sounds like some of them are coming forwards.
But is it all just being I think it's more down at this point?
Yeah, at this point, they'll just be different.
Right.
Originally way back when we were planning on just keeping the ascendancies as they were.
Yeah.
But at this point, that wouldn't even be good enough because like it doesn't fit the kind of like path of Excel to way of designing this thing.
So yeah, I mean, like we might have a class called the dead eye and it might have the same themes, but it'll be like different actual mechanics and different things.
Yeah.
I mean, yeah, even the dead eye, you got tailwind works differently.
You've still got an additional projectile.
You know, like there are there are things that certainly carry over.
But it's really easy and it's honestly been fun just looking at them going like, you know, now we have all these system changes, all these skills and everything works like this.
Just what would the perfect class be?
Not like how can we retrofit and band aid appear?
We want class to work.
It's just way better to look at it and go, here's all the things we want.
Yeah.
So well, yeah, like when you have now the life and mana flask and stuff, it could obviously things don't work quite the same.
But then now you have the charm system and also.
I actually wonder if Pathfinder would be cool with that.
Exactly.
About like stacking charms.
So it's it's just here are, you know, 12 eventually 36 classes.
It's not really like here's the peer we want counterpart and they're identical kind of thing anymore for sure.
Too many things changed for that to even be possible anyway.
Yeah. All right.
Sounds very epic.
We can skip over the flasks and trinkets as we did cover that very well.
So moving into skills, I realized I like had many pages of questions here and then I was like, wait, we haven't even talked about like skills here.
It's so much to so much to for us to discover over the course of this beta.
How is the list of skills been shaping up overall?
I mean, it's certainly getting there.
I mean, look, there are even certain skills that won't even make it even just within the classes we have.
Like there are still going to be more some more skills coming later on as well for the for these classes because there are more skills that we got just about there.
And yeah, it didn't quite didn't quite make it.
So yeah.
And like getting a class finished in terms of the skills you need, like it sort of seems very easy when you come up.
OK, we need like, you know, 22, 23, 24, you know, number of skills, something like that.
And it seems like that's not so many and you kind of design them.
But when you actually come up with all of the things, you know, the way they interact together, you know, the number of prototypes you have to do that kind of don't really work.
And, you know, like you end up not being fun.
And then, of course, the support, Jim stuff like you need to make sure that every skill has enough viable supports so that you can actually even recommend people to do.
Then you need things like the, you know, the passive tree support for all of them.
You need to have all of the the stuff with like buff, the buff gems for each character class as well.
You know, you need to be thinking about uniques for the for the type of, you know, for the that can work with these things.
It's just like there's so many different elements to actually make skills work.
And once again, it's another area, I think, that was underestimated to some degree before.
And, you know, like it does take a to actually get that finished.
It takes a lot. So, yeah, that's been a total struggle.
And we didn't think we would have to have only six character classes initially.
The start of early access, we were thinking we would have eight to begin with.
But, yeah, when it actually came down to actually getting to actually finish something, you know, like it just ended up being too much.
So, you know, now, obviously, we've got a bunch of work on more of the classes that we've done.
You know, there's things there.
But it's that finishing work of like making sure that all the systems in the game come together to support, you know, how that how that works.
That requires a lot.
Doing all of that as we're still discovering how we want those systems to work, you know, like the changes to support gems and all that.
As we're also making support gems, as we're making character classes just can cause things to slow down quite a bit.
And then we have to recalibrate and all.
Yeah, like it is it was an extreme amount of work that we certainly predicted poorly.
But that was also because we are making all these cool systems, all these changes to all these systems, which are having immense benefits as well.
So, yeah, I would say it's pretty safe to expect that, you know, as much as you can't play them on day zero,
a lot of some of those other classes that we have shown in the past and some of the skills and stuff, there's a lot there, like just not to make it seem like it's shallow or anything.
But we will be adding those classes in for sure.
Yeah, the thing that keeps like surprising me is well, when you click that old gems tab, when you're doing it on cut, there's quite a lot of skills in there.
But you initially kind of box yourself away where you think, OK, so I'm playing the mercenary, so I'm just looking at the crossbow skills.
And then I was like, well, what if I go look at the elemental skills and then I find flame wall and I'm like, oh, I can shoot my projectiles through that.
OK, cool. I like that. But that's like surface level because you also have the weapon swap thing and you can actually viably do with the automated weapon swapping.
It's not like toxic where you have to push the button a bunch of times and you've got the trees that like customize whenever you do it automatically on the fly.
All of a sudden I'm like, oh, well, why can't I use a sword on the other hand?
That's actually a very cool mercenary vibe sword and crossbow.
So yeah, I mean, that stuff is like is crazy. I mean, like in the in the actually there was one in the community guys recorded where they were using a bell, the bell skill with the quarter staff with the rapid shot mercenary skill.
And when I saw it, oh, man, you know, it's like a whole other thing. Yeah, like that. I didn't even know about that about that particular combo until I saw it in the some of the footage they recorded.
I started thinking about that too with like multiplayer. I was like, sorry, I was throwing my gas grenades, which you can blow up with your explosive grenades.
But then I was throwing at a boss that was doing burning ground and they were blowing up instantly. I'm like, oh, wait, so it reacts to the environment.
Well, it's obviously going to react to my friends doing burning ground. Oh, yes. Oh, yes. Oh, yes. And I'm a flame wall friend.
And this and this is the reason like this conversation here is the reason why there's going to be crazy builds that we don't anticipate because like the like like like some of the stuff that can happen between classes.
And we just have no doubt we will not have discovered. Yeah. Like how much have you really been able to test?
I mean, like we do test party play all the time. Marks, Marks, like the final words. I'm the support character player.
Now I'm like freezing armor breaking, putting down clouds slowly. You know, holy, there's just a lot going on.
And I'm not just standing there like I got buffs coming out of me.
You know, it's like, you know, you're like, I'm actually doing all this active support and like different conditions to synergize with the group and how you're doing that.
OK, what I'm going to do is I'm going to just do this and enhance my armor breaking and go ballistic armor breaking and you just spam your thing that consumes it.
You know, so you get a lot of that stuff going on for sure where I but you know, it it's kind of honestly the terrifying part as well where it's like.
What do we have? We had the whole like vulnerability curse with with gas cloud ticks or something and it was like literally applying armor break like every frame.
And so you have the monsters going to get armor explosion on there.
Yeah. And then you have some other thing. You have some other guy consuming it.
And again, I'm a guy cool rain. Just don't know how many bloody synergistic things with cool rain.
You can do a lot with that. All the lightning arrows on the ground and because they can, you know, lightning things hit them and explode.
And all of a sudden now you're just everyone's running around with cool rain spamming lightning rods everywhere.
Yeah. And frost wall. Somehow frost wall. We had about 15 abuse cases.
I mean, that's historically accurate. Yeah.
Can I blast frost walls and all that? It returns. Sounds like it's coming back.
It'll be fun. It's cool. Even finding all the stuff so far has been really fun.
But yeah, I generally play multiplayer. Most of the alpha I've done is being in multiplayer, play with other people.
It's good to get a lot of that testing in there as well. Not a lot of others do it.
And then, yeah, try and see what we can break just for good fun.
Honestly, the thing it's like hardest to then like because you get this thing, which is quite interesting.
We have a staff is both the player and a developer.
And I'm off the light. Don't you? You better not keep that.
You know, something that's I want to exploit, but you know, something that's Opie a secret, right?
You better tell me because you were saying people weren't telling you about exactly like you get a situation.
Someone doesn't want to tell you about their build, but because they're like, oh, Michael Nerf it then.
Like that's supposed to be making a meeting and, you know, whatever.
I was like, I swear, if I see any of you at the top of the ladder on day one, we're going to have a talk.
Exactly. Exactly. Exactly.
I did tell you about my flashbangs and maybe it's fine. I just don't. I just wanted them to check.
That is the thing that is hard. No one knows if the thing is actually brought.
Look, there's a line that gets crossed. Yes.
But sometimes you don't know, is it just I found something cool and it's powerful or have I found something cool and it's broken?
You know, and those things, I mean, we have to make those decisions, of course.
And a lot of the time what is reported is just fine.
And it's like, yeah, you've got a good weapon and you've got the right. You got this combo.
You're strong if it's if it's supported by items, then it's like fine to be very powerful.
But if you're just like, I just pick these skills and no matter what weapons I'm wearing, I'm just like completely ridiculous.
Then that's a different situation, because now it's just a thing that anyone can do at a moment's notice rather than actually requiring like, you know, I have to find the big combo of items and things like that.
So that's a much different story.
We've had a lot of good testing, a lot of good feedback, a lot of good people reporting that stuff, especially in the last month.
It's like coming in a lot because there's the systems and everything's kind of stabilizing.
You start to get a lot more of that.
And people are understanding what the difficulties meant to be and what the power of characters is meant to be as all of that came and started to stabilize.
We've got a lot more of this coming in and we are kind of getting more understanding.
But again, you'll never find them all. But, you know, it's fun. Good fun journey.
Support gems have changed a lot.
However, you found the changes to them being now having no levels and the restriction of having only one support gem on your character of a type, but having a lot more of them.
I really like how this works. I think that it adds so much more build diversity and interest to have to be making the decision of like, you know, where is this going to go?
And the thing that's been important, though, with that system is it requires a lot more support gems to exist because you need one on your character.
You need tons of them. And like you need like you need a lot of different ways to increase damage and a lot of ways to support different mechanics.
It's like if you're going to have something like freeze, like, you know, you're going to have a freezing skill.
You need to be able to support that and augment that and like many different ways.
And there needs to be more options than what you can even like there needs to be in order to have choice.
You can't just have five. Here's your five freeze things. And that's all you do. Right.
There has to be more than that in order to be able to have it. So you actually have some choices as well.
So that kind of stuff has meant that you just need a lot of things going on there.
But I think that the choices that you end up with as a player of like, you know, where do I put my model projectiles? Where do I put my piece?
I think that leads to a lot more interesting decisions with how you build and, you know, like, yeah, I think that to me is where a lot of the why it just works so much better.
And we were certainly hesitant about the whole, you know, you can only have one support per character thing because it sounds bad if you just hear about it as a player without actually playing it.
You just hear that. You're like, oh, it's just a restriction. And it is arbitrary in some sense. Right.
We can't justify it thematically, really. It's just it's just it is what it is.
And so I really don't like that kind of thing usually, because if I'm going to I want the theme to match the mechanic as much as possible.
But in this case, it just made the gameplay so much better that like it just had to happen.
So arguably, if you if you need to, if you end up in a situation where you like I have to put the support on every slot.
Exactly. That is less choice. And that's the reason why the gameplay is bad. Less choice, less interest.
And also, you may as well just bake that now into the skills and or 100 percent.
And so this is the thing. It is actually much worse to have that because it results in this outcome.
But like that's a kind of more subtle argument that's like you have to kind of make to people if you want to kind of convince them this is actually the right way.
Because when you tell people, oh, there's this restriction, it doesn't sound like what they're getting out of that is more choice.
It sounds like they're getting less. But the reality is it is actually more choice because you no longer have like mandatory like here's the here's the five mandatory things you have to put on the skill.
It's like is actually much more going on. I think it's much better helped realize my experience on the mercenary that you your vision of having like all of these skills available to you and them actually being worth using for sure.
Because if you had all the same support gems, I feel like you just pick the one that does the most damage and you make it do the most damage.
And that's the only skill you use. And I mean, the great thing is, is now it's completely reasonable to have a skill in your character that you just use occasionally.
Right. Like every five minutes, you might have a situation where you need to use that. And that's actually fine and completely reasonable.
Yeah. So I'm playing a Grenada and I would be like, OK, I should only use this grenade normally is what I would be like in part of exile because this is the best grenade or maybe this one that does like interacts with it in some way.
The obvious combo. But now I'm actually like, well, there's a reason I could use those lightning ones to apply shock because I have all these shock support gems that I'm not using anywhere else because I'm using the damage and the LMP on my big damage dealers.
I can use I can put the shock things on there and I can actually have a shock set up. I can incorporate that into my build. I can incorporate poison into my build to strip their armor and whatnot.
And maybe I only use that occasionally when you face something that's got heavy armor. Yeah. Yeah. It's like that. That's why I really want to be viable. And that situational stuff, I think, just makes the game way more interesting.
It's it's really feeding into the flavor of mercenaries like this, like prepared kind of fighter who has all these tools at their disposal as well.
Like, you're like, I have this grenade for if I get into this situation, this grenade for this one. It's like, I love it.
A couple of questions here. People definitely been asking about like vile skills and transfigured gems and stuff like that. I feel like this sort of thing doesn't make sense at launch.
Yeah, because ultimately, if we're going to add something like that, it would make sense to add it just as another skill.
So at this point, there's no real reason to do that. Like that kind of stuff comes in. We want to have a specific reward system somewhere that wants to be able to do that.
And so we don't really need to do it right now. But you look, we might decide to bring that theme back and, you know, in a reward system.
I think the vile skills, especially it's a cool flavor. Yeah, for sure.
But I think the transfigured thing is also interesting. Like, you know, if you're looking to be able to like the reason why transfigured was nice is because it's like we got to sort of iterate on a bunch of different themes around the same skill, which obviously at this point, we don't need to do that because we've got to.
We're already still adding the skills, you know what I mean? So all the iterations of it are like less of a necessary thing.
But yeah, I mean, I'm sure we'll be doing more stuff like that in the future. We absolutely will be.
Do you know how many skills roughly you have, Sasha, going to end up with?
You know, I actually don't know the number off the top of my head. But what I will say is that we initially, I think when we announced like what the full game would have, we said 240.
I'm pretty sure we're actually nearing that. I feel definitely it's going to be way higher than that.
Yeah, because we're nearing that now when we've only added half the classes.
So I think that that means that there's going to be a lot more than that.
Like a hundred or whatever, like some little utility skill or whatever. But there's even if you discount for those.
Yeah, I know. No, that's what I mean. Yeah, you got what?
Because there's 20 to 25 for each of those for each class. And so just with six of those, I'm terrible at math in my head.
But I feel like that's 120. Well, let's say it's just a bit over 110 or something.
End up around there. 120 something like that. Around. Yeah, I think probably 120.
Around there like that. But then you've also got all the buff gems as well. And like each character class has nine of those.
So that then sort of adds up. So you've already reached probably 200 just by the time you've got to there.
And then it doesn't even count things that really are skills, but like you don't get them via a skill gem.
So like we're talking about all the ascendancy little skills and there's like uniques that have little skill things on them.
All staffs, wands and sceptres have a skill back to them.
Exactly. We're not even counting that, right? Because the staffs, wands and sceptres have skills built in.
And then those are like, how many of those? There's like 20 of those probably.
Yeah, I mean. But if you add them all up. I don't know who remembers all these things.
No one has counted recently. But there's a bunch. Countless skills.
And there's ascendancy classes with skills. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Tons. Yeah.
And those skills, those skills, by the way, ascendancy class skills are fully supportable. Yeah.
Yeah, that's wild. Because I remember I did the thing with default attack where you can support that now.
You can support default attack and you can support any skill that comes from something.
That one caught me by surprise. I was like, oh wow, you can actually link those up.
Yep. It's yes. So you're going to end up with quite a lot going on there.
I was even surprised when I was like, oh, I can add, you know, additional accuracy to Herald of Ice.
And it like provides a buff to my character. I can like add buffs through support gems.
You know why that is though, because those things like Heralds are so hard to find like a good set of supports to recommend.
So like, damn, we have tons of these now. They're like really difficult.
You can like create a custom aura. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely.
So yeah, it's that actually mean it's actually nice because part of the it means that you get the feeling of having more aura effects on your character without having to have the spam of actual auras that every many characters had in here we won.
But you get to kind of have all that stuff as well. So that's been really nice.
Thanks for the invisible aura MTX.
Well, it does remind me though. So with all the is very off topic, but with all the very good teasers you've been doing for like new 3D art for Unix and stuff like that, have you had any thoughts about reworking the transfer skin transfer MTX in some way, making it more permanent?
Honestly, it's not in our thing about stuff we're thinking about, you know, like the same way it works for now, at least.
But obviously skin transfer in Peewee 2 there's a lot more cool base art.
Yeah, that's gonna make people actually want to use it now.
So you're probably using that a lot more.
So yeah, it'd be cool to see something for that in the future potentially.
So on to the end game, which was, I feel like a big bulk of the announcement for sure.
Yeah.
So just as like an overview. So we have the end game versions just for beta launch, by the way.
Because it's gonna be a lot more later.
So we have the end game pinnacle versions of the two trials.
So as like fully farmable content. They don't have trees though, those ones.
They don't have trees, but they do have a progression system of some kind.
So you've got the relics in the Sanctum sequel.
And then for the Trial of Chaos, you have the inscribed automatums have getting mods from the end.
So when you kill the final boss of that, which is alleged to be the trial master.
Alleged?
Yeah. Then he'll drop items that can then have mods on them to make the trial itself harder.
And there's also some pretty interesting ones on there that we actually were going to put in the video,
but it was starting to get a bit long, which was that you've got the thing,
where you've got the bets that you can make of like, put up 13 exalts,
and then you might get double that back if you're able to complete the thing.
So those are some of the mods that can spawn on there.
As well as mods that make the actual trial harder as well.
So there's things like that as well.
So yeah, those two have those kind of like different outside the Atlas tree,
because they're not really part of the Atlas.
You'll get keys for them while you're playing end game.
But technically speaking, they're kind of like, they scale to end game,
but they're not like sort of part of the whole Atlas.
You don't play them there.
Yeah, so they're their own distinct end game too.
So there'll be three rogue-like dungeon things that will be...
Sure, sure, sure.
...like distinct end games.
I wouldn't say three rogue-like dungeons.
I will say there'll be three trials that have various mechanics that can be different.
But then of course you've got the four, kind of what I guess would say sort of...
I don't know, we actually need a name for what...
What are we calling the things that are icons on the...
Because they were called leagues, but they're not really leagues.
Yeah, it doesn't really make sense to call it a league exactly.
That is what we call them internally.
We just refer to them as leagues.
There are four leagues that you have that appear there.
It doesn't really work anymore, does it?
I don't have a good idea right now.
We probably have actually named it. I just don't remember what it is.
And then you've got the kind of boss hunting kind of element as well.
And then I guess what you would say is the pinnacle of the kind of boss hunting thing is the end game.
You've got the cities with the lieutenants and then the Uber Act bosses.
And then above that you have the pinnacle boss who we don't want to spoil.
Although I did show you a little bit about it just in private before.
But yeah, that one's going to be hard.
I know you're cooking up some pretty difficult mechanics there.
Yeah, it's fun. That's the fun stuff.
Because now you don't need to worry about if people can't progress through.
It's not a progression blocker. You can just kill them.
It's a progression blocker to the higher difficulties though.
Because once you kill that, then you get the increase of the difficulties.
And then it's like, okay, now try it again, but way harder.
And then there's four levels of difficulty for each end game system like that.
So yeah, apart from the trials, the end game trials, everything has its own distinct passive tree.
And progression through them is also by doing them.
Yes, exactly.
So we really wanted to prevent the situation where you feel like you allocate points for a certain piece of content.
And then you feel like you can't do the other content because you're kind of wasting the points that you've got.
Yeah, the lock-in.
And we kind of band-aided that in P.O.E. 1 by adding multiple Atlas trees as a way.
But I think the solution is much better where effectively you can progress all of them.
And you can either do just all-in-one for a while, or you can just do each of them as you come to them.
And just add them kind of piecemeal.
But either way, however you want to do it, you can make progress on your character.
Well, I should say in your league for all of those.
Because the progress and all that stuff is of course for the whole league, not just for a single character.
Yeah, and previously we used the Atlas tree, I would say very much so, to make sure that we were doing the type of content that we wanted to do.
Yeah, so now it's not so much about finding the content because that's what the tablets are for.
Now it's more about improving your ability to sustain effectively.
You're going to want to have those points to get sustainability for the next level up.
We want to make sure that there is sustain if you're engaging with those mechanics well.
But effectively you do have to actually, to get sustain at higher difficulties,
you will need to be able to be making smart choices in terms of allocating and using the tablets correctly and that kind of stuff.
It is part of that sort of story of all of that.
So yeah, that's kind of the main thing with that.
Yeah, this idea of sustaining the content you want to do by doing it is a little different to how it's been in P1 a lot of the time.
Where it's like you had to fuel it by going back to maps.
I mean you're still doing maps ultimately, but effectively as long as you're doing the content that you want to do, and making it harder,
so your build has to be good enough to be able to sustain it, then you will be able to sustain that stuff.
If you want every single map to have a breach in it, that's absolutely doable by using the tablets correctly.
Yeah, so the Atlas passive trees and the trees for each of the distinct types of content is about scaling the reward and difficulty primarily.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, absolutely.
And what does, I saw like on the breach nodes it said like increased difficulty. What does that mean?
It's somewhat arbitrary and asymmetric, but it will feel like, for example, some of the difficulties will actually change the boss's skills and how they work.
Generally they'll increase like the level of the area, right, so you get the general monster and life scaling, but arguably to a player that's arbitrary as well, because they don't know how that scales.
And in other contexts here might be more of certain monster types, less of others and stuff like that.
It is generally that yes, the small nodes will increase difficulty of the meta content, whereas the large, the notables will increase the reward of the in-map content.
But when I say difficulty, that is reward as well. So an example of how this works is like, let's say the boss has six uniques it could drop, or five or six uniques.
It can drop three at difficulty zero, then at say difficulty one, it can drop, you know, maybe has increased level or higher item level, some rarity.
You know, now also that when I say rarity, also do note rarity does increase the grade of items, not just making them yellow or orange.
It does make them better yellows or better oranges.
It does affect, yeah, it affects other things about items than just the rarity.
Yes. And so yeah, when I talk about just getting rarity here, I don't want people to, in P1 players in particular, to think, ah, they're just going to go from yellow to more yellow.
So anyway, and, you know, maybe the next tier will add a unique to the pool, like a more, you know, what we hope will be more valuable unique.
And then the next one can do a bit more rarity, something else maybe introduce a different unique perhaps.
And then the last difficulty introduces something ideally, you know, without giving away exact specifics of them, more in the line of a modular unique item, say like Megalomaniac or like Forbidden Flesh and Flame from P1.
So a unique item that is like ideally very powerful, very chase, but has a lot of different combinations.
Watchers Eyes, another good example, right?
So a new series of jewels is a good example.
There are other uniques that are modular and stuff, and that comes in at the last tier.
And so you want to really be getting to that hardest difficulty.
So you can be getting these like farming for these extremely good, powerful, unique items.
But of course you have the thing if you're never ready for it, if you try it and you're like, oh, this is too hard, you can always just respect the nodes.
You can unspec them away and then not, you know, like just effectively decide like I've got these points, but I'm not.
Yeah, I want to go back and do this later.
And so that ability to effectively configure the difficulty like that, I think.
So if you're maybe target farming one of the base, one of the uniques, the difficulty zero drops, you might want to just be like, I'll do that.
I'll do the difficulty stuff later and I'll just farm it at this difficulty.
And I think that's a much better way than some of the systems have used to scale down in the past.
And the nice thing is, of course, with difficulty is that we can effectively get what use whatever scaling levers we want to make that more difficult without necessarily having to like,
because we could have been like, oh, you know, you increase difficulty, it's like 200 percent life or something like that.
But by effectively being a bit more vague about it, we can actually like specifically tailor the difficulties of the different tiers, like, you know, with more specific changes.
Yeah, this like multiple projectile thing you shoot has more projectiles.
Sure, and that kind of thing.
So, you know, whatever we feel works best for making this particular fight more difficult.
It seems like there's a lot more players to kind of discover experimentally there as they progress.
For sure.
In what way are they getting harder?
And that is going to be different for different players, too, where like a different build is affected by a difficulty change more so.
Potentially.
And that's an interesting question as well, I think, where how much are you guys pitching these sorts of distinct end game pieces of content at being like completable by the same build or by encouraging players to make a different build that's better at certain content?
So this is this is a very difficult one.
And it's something that we've discussed a bit recently is like the harder you make the hardest content, the less builds will be considered viable by the players because effectively like a build is only viable if it can defeat like, you know, the pinnacle boss at difficulty four.
That would be kind of the general perception.
So we have to be really like I actually don't know necessarily what the right answer here is.
Like we have the ability.
I mean, maybe you feel like you do, but I don't think I wouldn't say I'm 100 percent confident on it.
But, you know, I'll I'll have a go at it.
Look, there's going to be iteration here because what we'll see is like, you know, if we find that like, you know, there's only like some particularly abuses like only the most abusive stuff is possibly able to defeat the hardest content that we might have to dial it back a bit.
Yeah, but it's kind of going to be a bit of experimentation.
And it's very hard at this point to be able to pitch that because we don't have the crazy, you know, P we do does not have the history of P we won to be able to, you know, to know kind of what like what is the right life value to have on a difficulty for pinnacle boss.
Like, yeah, how do we even know that at this point really without that being said, though, like the bosses are a lot more skill based and tactical.
Right. Like at the end of the day, the gear is to some degree necessary because no one can really make no mistake for some amount of time.
You know, so you do have that thing and you do need to mitigate certain things.
But like a lot of these are like very dodge roll tactical or using certain skills or mitigation tactics or whatever you do.
There's heaps of different things to bypass the things that make them hard for sure.
But I would say it is very much a lot of skill is involved, especially when it comes to some of these with dodge rolling.
Like I'm trying to emphasize that quite a bit or blocking, you know, if you want to do a different way about it.
I'm not to say you must block, but yes, dodge roll is a pretty key mechanic here.
And I'd say we're certainly upping the emphasis on using and using it well as you get into these higher tiers.
But gears always a way and combinations of uniques and passively and build is always a way to go.
I'm not good at dodge rolling. I'm going to get around that skill check and become strong enough to defeat the boss.
You know, or another skill like some sort of skill that helps you block or using skills in the mix is fine.
Yeah, but I would say pretty generally you can take I'd say any decent character you get pretty damn you get up all the way.
And as long as you're good enough, that is a way to defeat them.
I would say there's no real hard requirement on doing something crazy niche or out there or complicated.
You're certainly not going around of like, oh, this boss is fire immune or something.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no. Thanks.
We've been through that already.
Yeah.
Excellent. So this this very cute Atlas, this infinitely expanding civilization map,
ask Atlas, which I know you're particularly fond of, Jonathan.
Yeah.
What's the what's kind of the idea here?
Like, is the layout the same for everyone?
Is it the same across the league?
So it's the same for your characters in the league, but the layout is different for everyone.
It is random. So you're going to have to find stuff like it works like delve in this respect,
which is obviously a league that I was particularly a fan of.
So yeah, I'm still really I like I what I really wanted is I wanted a feeling of exploration in the Atlas.
And it's something that we sort of tried to do with the Atlas and we won with that feeling of kind of,
you know, having the connected areas and exploring, but it never really it didn't feel like exploration quite
in quite the same way that this does. Yeah.
So that's something I loved.
It was one of the reasons I love Delve.
And so that's, you know, kind of kind of where this was coming from.
And at the same time, it's sort of solving various other problems that we've always had where like one of the things
that's really cool to do is to be able to have things like, OK, like in this area, you've got like this item drops
and like that kind of thing, you know, like I guess in P1, you have Div cards.
But there was always a problem where if you have differences between in-game areas in a system that works like P1 does,
then effectively that's the only map people like whatever the best map is, that's the one everyone will run forever.
So effectively, we wanted to try and make sure that you actually like had an experience that had more variety
while still retaining the whole like I get to play the content that I want.
So ideally with the with the Atlas, we kind of get that we've got in P2, we get to kind of have both of the best of both worlds.
We get to make sure that there is some variety, you know, you feel like you're exploring.
But because once you've run a map that's run and now you have to move on and do it and find another one.
It's not just like the, you know, like just just play one map again and again and again.
But yet the content, you know, can be added to it.
You can do things if you if you like the particular maps, you know, because there are biomes and you can see them from far away.
You can be like, OK, I know there's a particular desert map that's great.
So I'm going to go for deserts and that's fine. You can do that kind of thing.
So, you know, like you've both got controllability, but also, you know, the ability for us to kind of make more variance.
You get a lot more very high satisfying spikes. Yeah.
Well, like, for example, you get more variables where you just have, OK, there are like four towers.
Really, you got a good tower cluster and you've got really good maps in that range.
So like, you know, there are maps and perfect.
So one, for example, you know, the range is effectively say, how do I quantify this?
Like, say, 350 monsters up to 700 monsters. Yeah.
Whereas the range here is like 300 monsters up to like 1500 monsters, you know, much, much, much more drastic range.
Now, those numbers are up. Sure. But it is approximately the representation of the range.
Obviously, you then modified and add more to it and all of that.
So you will have some maps that are like extremely good with Delirium and some maps that are like way better with something more like Breach.
Yeah. Because Delirium enhances the monsters of the map, whereas Breach entirely adds the monsters.
And you will even have things where there are maps that are like way more magic monsters, way more rare monsters.
And so you probably want that with, you know, pick your league of your choosing and what not.
You have all these variables that are at play.
And so you all of a sudden find a really good set of towers with some really good maps and radius.
And then you'll get really good tablet modifiers and then you'll get really good maps with really good prefixes.
And you want to just combine all of this and you obviously instill them all and you corrupt them all.
And there's the corruption influence.
And so then there's the corruption influence on them.
And it's like, OK, like.
It is possible for this on one map to be many, many mechanics stacked to the point of craziness.
So it sounds like the juicing is definitely there.
Well, yeah, I mean, that's important, right?
I mean, like that's part of the POE experience.
Yeah, for 100 percent.
But how much control do you have as a player though over min-maxing your just exploration of the Atlas map?
So effectively.
Can you do better in some way?
So effectively what you're going to want to do is the towers are where you go to like see areas around.
And then the structure of the connections is quite open.
So like you can be lined for things pretty well.
Like if you like you can certainly see a lot more maps than what you play, if you know what I mean.
Yeah.
So because of that, like, you know, choosing what you want is easy to do.
And you can kind of see the towers in the fog.
Yes, you can see the towers in the fog from a distance, which means that, you know, like a lot of the time it's like, you know, go to a tower.
You'll see some maps you want to play.
You go play those.
Then it's like the next tower is just a few other maps away.
Go to that tower.
See the next area and so on.
I'm guessing that's like a certain range that you can see.
Yeah, the fog kind of in 3D kind of the fog is actually a 3D thing and like it like rises slowly as he gets away from where they are.
So that's how you kind of get the towers.
So you might see a cluster of towers off somewhere.
Yeah, absolutely.
It sounds like this is like potentially an infinitely expanding map that is going to be by the end of someone's league quite big.
Yes.
So we actually need to add a search feature.
I don't know if they've done it yet for finding specific maps that haven't been run yet.
We have a few things that there's a button you can press and it like goes to your last map round one that goes back to a home base and one that goes to some of the special, you know, more iconic things you find.
But this we certainly need more.
100%.
So that is something we will be working on.
Hopefully it's there.
Who knows?
And so way stones have a tier, but they don't have specific maps on them anymore, which obviously shrinks that whole map pull thing down.
Yes, substantially.
It'll make the maps dash tab a little easier to manage.
So, yeah, so have you thought about like what sort of economic consequences that have for like how players progress through maps?
Is it easier to do when you don't have to collect all of these individual maps to get the completion bonuses and stuff like we do currently?
Like we have that whole, you know, hunting down over 100 maps to get completion for.
I mean, yeah, now you're hunting, you know, you're hunting certain valuable maps, you're hunting towers, you're hunting content, you're hunting, you know, the warlord, the faction leaders to get the pinnacle.
You know, you're hunting unique maps, very different thing for sure.
As opposed to and then the item is all about, I've just got a key.
I just want good modifiers, you know, there's not really all that whole other variable to it.
So there's still a lot of lot of interesting choice and axes, but we've taken it from the item and put it on the actual world map.
But it's cool. It also makes you just feel like you're traversing a world, you know, you're not instantly like finishing the campaign very grounded.
And now I'm in space, you know, like I only literally just thought about that.
I was going to ask about that. So, you know, the mapping system was always this like extra dimensional kind of unknown thing.
It's pretty interesting, but it is a little weird.
So we wanted to start with actually like at least I mean, look, I'm sure we'll get to the extra dimensional beings eventually.
But at least to start with, you know, we want to have a bit more grounded initially.
Yes, you're on the planet.
You're on the planet.
That's like a good thing.
We've become a sci-fi crazy.
But yeah, you know, you haven't gone to the moon yet.
Yes, I'll get.
Well, even then we were saying like, can we at least at least before we go to outer space, go to the moon first?
Actually, how many moons are we don't know?
There's a whole complicated thing we need to figure out there.
I feel like there's a delve, but up league coming.
All right.
So we've got this one in four maps is boss maps.
And then that means the other three are not boss maps.
Yes. What does a non boss map look like?
How do you win it?
So effectively, what you need to do is kill the kill the rares in the map to remove the corruption and finish it.
Once you get down below 50 monsters, it will point out any rares that are remaining.
They're going to market just so you know.
But honestly, I wouldn't expect that to even be necessary most of the time because the layouts are kind of designed so that, you know, like, you know, if you generally speaking, you want to clear the maps to find the rares anyway, because those are the one, you know, those have good drops.
And effectively, the only reason that you would need that market thing is just occasionally get some slightly weird, generic layout where there's some side but you didn't notice or something like that.
And that's like that's where you have to go.
So generally speaking, you'll be able to make your way around and kill them all.
The goal of the player is you're cleansing corruption from the world.
You'll bring the order back, you know, stuff like that.
So you even get the thing on the map where you're like, you know, there's some corruption looking stuff around the map when you complete the map that gets purged away, you know, so you feel like you're reverse painting the map a little bit.
Cleaning up to it can actually be quite satisfying as you're like changing all the nodes from one color to another.
And you're like, yeah, this is fun.
Ultimately, what we wanted to do is we wanted boss combat in POE 2 to matter when we have it.
Yeah. And so in order, like if you have a map boss every area, then if we made it so the boss combat mattered enough, like in order to actually balance it that way, it's too much.
Like it actually is like, you know, you spend too much of your time fighting bosses.
So effectively, if that's what you want to do now, you can do it because there's bosses there.
You know, like when I say one of four maps is a map boss, that doesn't mean that one for maps you play as one.
Because, you know, obviously you can pick what content you're doing by exploring around.
You can chain your boss.
You're picking your path and your path.
Exactly. So effectively, if you want to hunt the bosses, then that is the thing you can do.
If you want to just like do some mindless grinding for a while, you can do that too.
And what it means is we can actually make the bosses way more rewarding.
They can drop way more items than they were going to because of the fact that there's not one at the end of every area, right?
And the fight is substantial, you get a lot of drops.
So that actually is something that...
And they get their own tree.
And they...what? Oh yeah, I know, right. You mean the boss killing tree.
The boss killing tree. Yes, there's a tree for boss hunting.
Sorry, I thought you meant every boss had its own tree.
I was like, Jesus, did you do some design well?
Not yet. Not yet.
So I was just like, wait, no, wait, stop.
It's too much.
That's like a year three feature.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, we'll keep that in mind.
Yeah, so there's actually like a...I do love that there's a boss hunting because I'm super into that.
There's a boss hunting tree that you can fill out as well.
So how do you get points on that?
Yeah, so effectively, I mean, well...
You get a lot of points for the core tree.
There's a core tree that affects all mapping.
All of things like pack size, quant rarity, and you've got multiple keystones that all can work together and all can...
So I think there's three of them.
One plays on like corrupted maps.
One plays on like prefixes and suffixes.
And I can't remember what the other one does right in this very moment.
But you obviously get that core tree and then you have a boss tree and then obviously all the different league and pinnacle content trees.
So you get those points by just completing maps.
It just has a...you effectively get a quest.
And effectively, it's like you complete ten maps, you get your first two points, and then like complete X maps and Y maps.
But of certain tiers.
At least tier one, at least tier two, at least tier three.
So this is the tier climb effectively, where it's like as you get up the higher tiers and clear maps of certain tiers, that's when you start getting points for the atlas.
And like, may I say the third one, I can't remember the exact specifics, it's like complete this and defeat a boss.
And then later it's defeat at least five bosses at something.
So killing bosses generates...
It sounds way better for fresh starts.
I'm not having to go and get that STO map that I missed or something.
Yeah, oh yeah, for sure.
I'm just doing content.
But it is kind of the analogue of that in a way, because it's that feeling of like I've got a system to progress through.
Like I just need to beat these objectives.
Definitely got a lot of progression.
And from that you're getting the atlas passive points and so on.
So yeah, that's kind of the idea.
Yeah, so you can really like focus in on map blasting with bossless maps or on bossing content if you want to.
Or on breaches.
And you can always put a breach on a map with a boss, right?
You can do both.
You can have every type of content on one map if you want.
Yeah, is like a boss map a kind of like a distinct thing from like a regular map in terms of like the layout or the thing you've done?
Technically they are separate, but generally speaking...
They're like similar versions of each.
They're basically the same.
They're pretty similar.
So they'll be like a boss as during and a non-boss as during.
Yeah, there are some cases at the moment where there are some maps that can't have a boss.
And it's just we haven't done the...
The one that would go here is not in early access yet and that kind of thing.
But effectively, you know, as I said, generally speaking, it'll be one in four that you'll find.
Okay, excellent.
So I think that covers...
Did I miss some things from...
You've got like all the smaller contents like the strong boxes and essences and things like that coming back as well.
Yeah, so initially we actually had a design where everything...
Like even all the smaller content, there were still going to be icons for it on the tree.
Sorry, on the atlas.
But we actually found that it meant that when you were actually exploring, it didn't kind of...
It felt like there was nothing random to find.
So we wanted to make sure we also have kind of just completely random stuff that doesn't have a progression system that you just run into randomly, because that's fun too.
And we'll probably be adding more stuff like that as well over time.
There's just like just the...
You randomly encountered this and that was like not expected.
So that's a lot of stuff on the core atlas tree.
So you can kind of like see more of that if you want to.
Yep. Great.
And often mods on the items as well.
On map. On keep waystones.
Yeah, cool. Yep.
Lots of different names. Maps, waystones, same thing.
Yes, I've had to keep kind of correcting myself about that.
I was like, I don't know.
Internally, we definitely call them maps all the time.
The thing is, the only reason why it doesn't make sense thematically is because a map does imply it's of a specific location, whereas a waystone can take you to anywhere.
So that's the reason why the name change had to happen.
But I think that probably even players will probably just call them maps I bet.
Just because, you know, if it's the peer we want to mention.
So we've got the Breach, Delirium, Ritual, Expedition, those like leagues that maybe need a new name.
Is there another one that you're just both personally really keen to bring back in the future?
I mean, you know, like I've always wanted to have Delve again, but I kind of got a bit of that wish with the system.
It's also a very like content heavy league to make because you need to make tons of encounters and doing it probably is a huge thing.
But I mean, look, I love Incursion as well. It's one of my favorites.
Like I'm keen for that. I don't know if there's anything you other than that you're really keen for.
There's a lot, especially because there's a lot I can do with we can do with all this new art, new monsters, new monsters, right?
Like, for example, if you just take Legion, Legion had all those five civilizations.
We've now got an entire new array of vile monsters, vile bosses, etc. that we can use as a baseline.
We've got way better consistent direction on what's going on there.
You know, heaps of stuff, new animation and the capacities are just out of control.
But then you've got OK, Incursion, we've got, you know, awesome vile artwork we can use there and make that all awesome and nice new corruption mechanics that we can extrapolate on.
Don't have a roof as the boss anymore.
Now you're not just have a floating roof.
The only text is just a small floating roof.
Keeping the theme of vacuum cleaners.
Look, mistakes were made.
Now we have minimum, that's a world where you had super uniques with one or two skills.
Right.
I don't, there's only so much you can do with a floating roof.
So anyway, and then, I don't know, even like bestiary coming back with something because we've got all these awesome bosses way grander in scale.
And you can do these more grand hunts for them as opposed to just like, oh, I'm like in a city and there's a rare spider, you know.
You can just get way, way more epic and way more, you know, involved and with all the new art and so much stuff to like.
Bestiary 2 that's like hunting big beasts and preparing for them and tracking them.
That'd be pretty cool.
Exactly.
I'd definitely take some mercenary action to that.
That'd be a good fit, I feel.
All right.
Well, there's lots for us to look forward to there.
You have some kind of like penned already for adding to the beta.
I mean, we all plans can change, but they're absolutely.
I mean, look, we've done things like commissioning art assets and so on.
Like we've got stuff coming along.
It's just a question of like, you know, when we actually get there, what's it going to look like?
Yeah.
All right.
Let's talk about crafting a little bit because we've done a lot there and it's pretty fundamental to the game, I think.
So what's the core of what you're trying to do with crafting in Path of Exile 2 compared to Path of Exile 1?
Kind of noting that you've really kind of stepped back from the idea of like reforging an item many times or scouring it.
So we really want to make it so that you're finding crafting items all the time.
You're using those crafting items way more often than you were in Path of Exile 1.
That, you know, just the game of like picking something up, like seeing what I could modify it to,
and then actually equipping those items just happening way more often.
And there's so many subtle changes around this, like in terms of just like the way that the base mod scale and items
and the things like that, like all the stuff to kind of make it so that as you find new base types and new things,
like you've got a reason to craft them, part of that is making sure that you've got enough of that currency.
You know, it actually took us a long time to even get comfortable with the idea of making something like an exalt drop that often.
Because there's just this thing in your cemented in your mind of like, you know, this is rare, right?
Like it's an exalt, how can it possibly drop like multiple times in that one?
You know, like it just seems crazy.
But with the way like removing scouring affected so much of the way that we craft.
Like I know that you noted earlier that there's so many more things you're allowed to craft now that you weren't allowed to before.
You can craft relics.
Yes, and the reason why that's allowed is because without scouring, like those crafts become one time things,
which means that it's actually okay to allow for that stuff.
And I think that's opened up a huge amount of stuff.
You know, there's just, yeah, there's so many more types that can be crafted.
And add so much more valuable value to the dropped item as well.
Exactly, exactly.
So that stuff is just, I think, opened up a huge amount there.
And it also has and this wasn't necessarily an explicit goal right at the beginning,
but it's also made that the game of like, I'm just going to click, click, click, click, click again and again as my crafting session is no longer really the matter.
It's a spam roll.
Yeah, exactly. Like everything kind of is something that you want to be able to use.
You are still reforging and meta crafting things.
We've got stuff like that, right?
You've got a Nulls.
But that stuff is higher up.
That's kind of more of a later game thing.
It's not spam.
Yeah, exactly.
Because you have to think about it after each time.
Like, will I improve this? Will I make it worse?
So yeah, there's stuff to do there.
And like, you know, like the meta crafting that Omens can do is also very interesting.
Like there's some pretty powerful stuff there.
But once again, we introduce that stuff later on.
And so effectively we want to, you know, I guess for lack of a better word, democratize crafting at early levels.
Like make sure that everyone's able to do that stuff while having the more advanced stuff be kind of a little bit later.
We certainly had a goal at one point where I was talking with Rishi and I'm like,
if every single time we're doing alpha wipes or getting the staff to play,
I am like, if I am not seeing and hearing about people using Exults during Act 1,
then we have failed and we need to drop more of them.
And so we ended up like, I would say honestly, in the last month,
we have like over like 8 to 10 times the amount of currency dropping, you know,
and you know, there's the cool things about it as well, which are the subtle things like a boss is way more likely to drop the higher tier currencies and stuff.
Because again, rarity affects that as well now.
So you're like way more incentivized to go and kill bosses to get them.
And there's heaps of awesome stuff around there.
But we're actually now finding people are exalting gear during the campaign, throwing it on weapons and building weapons from scratch.
You find a very good transmute, org, regal, exalt, exalt, you know, that process is like.
Transmute, org, regal, exalt is like a thing that you're doing often.
Yeah. And like enjoy and you know, like you find good bases and you do stuff with that.
I can speak to that experience.
So I've played probably six-ish hours most of the way through Act 2 on my mercenary and I've found maybe six or seven exalts.
I took a ring from like a one blue stat ring that had a nice roll, maybe a nice life roll or something,
and crafted it up to six property rare.
And I crafted a crossbow that I found with good sockets that had a good damage roll on it.
And I took that to six properties with multiple damage mods.
And I'm like each time that power is going up and I was I was I was doing that.
It feels good. I felt like the bottom line was regals, which was actually kind of interesting because I don't know if that's intentional.
Just luck, because I did really have to think about which blue items were good enough to take to a rare so that I could then put my exalts on them.
So you get more of those by disenchanting rares.
Yeah, they are farmable. So they are farmable, which is completely intentional.
We want to make sure that like if you don't have enough of those like so you get so generally speaking, it's like you're going to want to keep like I feel like once you get like more than like five or six transmutes, then you stop disenchanting blues and start selling them instead.
And the same thing could be true also for for regals, where it's like, OK, once you've got more than a certain amount, then you're like, OK, I can stop having to disenchant the stuff and kind of switch over.
But the nice thing is, is like when you don't have enough, there is a way to get them, which I think is really important.
And the same is true with the socket currency as well, where it's like, you know, when you don't have enough, you can start salvaging.
I know you were telling me you were buying stuff from the vendor with sockets in order to salvage it.
I surprised them with my methods.
Yeah, yeah.
So that stuff, you know, it's just really nice to have that for people to have the ability to, you know, to get that stuff when they need it.
And so it's nice that like all that really basic stuff of just like getting items to better tiers is now way easier to get.
And that solved a problem that we had through quite a lot of the betas where people were saying they didn't feel they had enough control.
Like they didn't feel like they had a way to advance their character when they needed to, to be able to solve specific problems.
And I think the socket thing really has helped a lot with that now, because now we've have a way finally to be like, OK, if I need a bunch of fire resist, there is a way to get that.
And I've got the tools to do it and I've got items I can use to do this stuff.
So that has helped a huge amount, I think, of solving those like, you know, issues that come up with your character.
And this is to confirm how you've solved BenchCrafting.
Exactly.
We went through so many iterations of bench stuff.
It was like a huge thing.
We implemented tons of UI, like there was tons of wasted time there implementing crafting.
The problem that we had was that the systems that we were making, it's like we could balance them in the ways the players were happy with.
And then the designers were very unhappy or we could balance them the way the designers are happy with and the players are unhappy.
And it's like when you've got a system where like you're fighting the players for what, how the balance should be.
You can tell that means you have a system that is bad.
But I think we were very, like I myself honestly was too slow to recognize the fact that a complete overhaul was needed.
And then at some point we actually, the socket stuff originally came from the Vaal Orb, like it was designed there.
And then at some point, I don't know who came up with it, I think it might have just been you, who said like, why don't we just put...
Nah, I appreciate it.
Rishi thought of that? Okay, yeah.
So Rishi thought of the idea of like, hey, what if we just put sockets, you know, in an early game?
What if you got them in Act 1?
What if you had runes that would let you get the base as the way of solving the remedial crafting problem?
So then suddenly, as soon as we do that, it's like, oh, like I'm happy, you know, players are happy, everyone's happy.
So that means we have a good system that is working and gets those good feelings.
So that I think was a real win.
And, you know, yeah, I love how that system is feeling at the moment.
Yeah, so the bench was achieving two things kind of in its way, which was maybe even three.
Gear customization for one, like you take an item and you can do something more to it, firstly.
And then you've got the problem fixing of like, oh, I need a bit more fire resistance.
And then the third thing was like the meta crafts.
Yeah, yeah.
So you've handled those each in different ways.
Exactly.
The runes, which do the first two things, the customization and the problem fixing.
So early on...
But I think the customization is even it's the soul cores.
Like the runes are more about the kind of like, I need to fix resistances.
Whereas the soul cores are more about like, I want to customize my items in different ways than what I would otherwise normally be able to do.
And then, of course, you've got the omens to solve the meta crafting problem.
So effectively, we move stuff around.
And essences as well.
Yes, of course.
So, yeah, essences, what they allow you to do is get two deterministic mods.
So because you can upgrade to blue and the...
But you can also upgrade from blue to rare with an essence as well.
So that lets you kind of get some of that stuff.
And then plus some of the omen things you can...
Yeah, there's stuff you can do there that is, I think, going to be pretty interesting.
And that's just at the start of release.
Yeah, because obviously there's going to be more, of course, as we add more things.
So, yeah.
So I was like, I was worried that, you know, some of the changes you're making might move us away from some of the like deep impact for crafting that we have.
But it sounds like you are still allowing like powerful meta crafting and the ability to make like a really good item.
For sure.
But you're also making sure that like the physical item itself that you find matters more.
Absolutely.
And I mean, like the more subtle...
That's what it's all about, right?
There's so much more going on, I think, just like clever things we've done with the item system as well.
Like one of the things I love that we did is we've made it so that...
So we've got blue and yellow chests you can find now.
And we've changed the world generation so that if a dead end is generated, the chance that you get a rare chest there is way higher.
So effectively, if a rare chest will spawn in the area, then it will choose dead ends first to go there.
We feel better about that.
Yeah, so that means that we effectively mean that like when like it makes the world feel like, you know, as far as item drops go, they're like, oh, like it feels intentional, right?
Like, oh, I went down into this dead end room, but look, there was a rare chest there.
So I feel happy about it.
You know, like that kind of thing is really cool.
So there's things like that.
But there's also the way that, yeah, so we've alluded to it a few times, but the way that rarity now works, where the mods get better as rarity increases, and also things like the you get better currency rather than just...
Yeah.
It means we don't have to have like the spam of items that's like crazy.
Like you actually feel like the that you kill a boss and it drops good shit as opposed to just lots of shit.
So, you know, that's the that's that's that's I'm a big fan of how this feels.
I think it's a lot better.
But it does mean though, of course, if you're a P1 player and you see a boss kill, like the number of like the expectation of like a P1 player sees like looks at the amount of spam on the screen in some to some level as the way of like knowing how good the drops were.
Now, of course, you got item filters and everything.
We have quantity brain, right?
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Yeah, exactly.
That is a good way of putting it.
So, yeah, it really is more about like, is the is are the items actually good?
Like, ideally, you kill a boss and you pick every item that drops up, you know, like that is a that to me is a win.
And I think we've we're basically getting at that point.
Yeah, I quite like how the exploration systems and that as well with the chess down dead ends and things like that acts as a player leveler in some ways.
We're like, yeah, the more you explore, the more stuff you find.
And that's true as well for the optional encounters around the place as well.
If you're if you're struggling, go fight some optional content, there'll be stuff there that can that can drop and, you know, that then you will definitely find things and lots of guaranteed rare rare items here and there.
And I like that.
This little boss here will drop a cast a rare cast item and heaps of stuff.
And the funny thing about that is that stuff like the came about a little bit from the fact that we actually had a problem where people were just face tanking bosses and dying over and over again.
They keep on respawning and they would never be like, oh, I'm going to go away and actually find some of the stuff.
And so I was thinking for a long time about like, well, why is it that in other games that people don't do that?
Like if I'm playing Elden Ring and I die to a boss like, you know, 10 times, I'm not just going to like just just continue doing that.
I'm going to be like, oh, maybe I'll go do something else for a while.
So we realized that the map like the idea of just there's lots of stuff to find like is actually a really important part of that.
So in Pewee 2 now, one of the recent things that's taking a lot of work from from people to get this working.
But now all of that, there's a you can see all the sort of weird side encounters that have specific drops on the map.
And that means that, you know, if you're if you're having trouble with the boss, you know, you know what?
I'm just going to go do some other stuff and then you'll come back and you will be powerful enough to kill the boss much more easily because you do absolutely find the rewarding things.
Yeah, there's a little chest on there or a little campsite.
Yeah, there's lots of little hard cut of drops from specific bosses.
They only the hard cut of drops.
They only drop one time.
So you can't just find them endlessly.
Yeah.
But effectively, if you go do all that side content and you check it all off, you'll get some very rewarding stuff.
Yeah, you got some pretty clever systems there.
And I definitely noted that I was using the map thing a lot to be like, oh, well, to be completionist about it.
But also, yeah, just being aware of like, oh, cool.
There was some there's some good stuff in this on that I can come and find.
And I think we figured out that like that some of that stuff reveals after you like find the waypoint in a zone.
That's how it works.
Yeah, it's either there's a few.
It's like either because an NPC told you about an area in which case it just happens to be revealed or the very least.
Yes. When you get there, generally, it's just when you get there, you see everything.
But there's a few different conditions that will reveal everything.
Kind of depends.
Like a lot of people just click through the dialogue so they'll never know the NPC told them.
But they check in my map kind of like when I went into a zone and then maybe afterwards to see if there was anything.
But like you never get to an area and don't see some unless they are like very obviously hidden intentional secrets that there's no they might be there.
They might not have found half of your key for your secret quest.
Oh, yeah, yeah. Don't worry about that.
So pivoting into economy and trading, the exchange from Path of Exile's one experiment recently,
we got a chance to actually try that live in the field.
And it seems from the player's perspective, it was a smash hit.
Definitely for us as well. Yeah, I got solved a lot.
I'm like we're 100 percent on board with that.
It's very good.
It was the least stressful league I ever played.
I mean, what normally caused almost all the anger and friction for me was was was yes, especially bulk trading.
It was horrible. And I was like, oh, this is like a dream come true.
Myself and so many other players, I feel like we're more engaged in endgame.
We were able to do the thing we wanted to do more.
And we're just less aggravated moment to moment basis.
That's good. So do you take that then as like as a big positive for it going into Path of Exile 2?
100 percent.
And how do you feel like it adapts to the game being quite different in the end?
Because they are pretty different games.
Like the economy works a bit differently.
I mean, honestly, I think I think it will just work.
I mean, look, we don't we have no idea what the trade values will settle on and like how that'll end up.
But yeah, like we're going to be chaos is going to be.
Yeah, but ultimately, I think that the trades effectively settlers was a test of what the trade
of what the economy will be like in Pewee 2 and to some extent because of the way that we did the gold and everything.
Yeah. So I'm pretty confident that that's going to be OK.
But obviously, you never know. Right.
Like when lots of people hit the economy, what can happen?
Hopefully we don't cause like horrible hyperinflation or have some horrible issue like that.
But I guess, you know, part of partly this is what what an early access is to find out.
Right. Like whether there's any issues.
Was there any economy testing?
Was there any surprises with that or with gold in terms of how things panned out?
Thankfully, not honestly.
Like we were worried, but thankfully none of the like horrible situations came to pass with that and ended up working just fine.
So, yeah, like it went great.
Who'd have thought 10 years later, we'd be back here saying, you know what?
Gold was a good idea.
Exactly.
Because I remember 10 years ago, this game's brilliant.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stupid gold.
The funny thing is, is I don't think we would have arrived at the way gold is now if we had had it in the first place.
Yeah. Like the non-tradability of whether they're using it as a sort of marker for how much play you've done.
I just I don't think that we would have ever had that way if we hadn't arrived from here.
So, yeah, I think that path dependency kind of did matter.
So, yeah.
The paths we weave.
So, how likely then based on just how successful it is, are you to want to expand the like exchanges capabilities to like other things like maps or waystones or even gear?
Well, I mean, look, I'm interested in this, but I don't think it's necessary right now.
So we're not going to in early access, at least we're not going to launch with any expanded stuff in that way.
But I guess I do want to sort of see how it works.
And I'm interested in potentially trying something like that in the future.
I just don't like the currency exchange was like 90 percent of the problem.
Yeah. And so fixing that like fixed a lot of the you know, like it seemed like there would be we would need to do more initially.
And then maybe now it's like maybe we don't.
But I still I still want to experiment with it potentially.
So, you know, I'm interested to see how it goes.
But yeah, the currency exchange definitely helped a vast amount.
Those were the annoying trains. Yeah, they were.
Yeah, definitely.
Great.
So we've had some.
Well, so this is a tricky question to answer, especially if we could just scroll down.
Yeah.
So what are you aiming for in terms of Path of Exile 2 is kind of like personal player economy and progression.
So how much resources you're acquiring, how you're using them, but also how much are you getting from trade versus from yourself?
I mean, this is a tricky question, but I mean, I think that really the feeling of being able to trade is super important.
So being able to get that stuff, I think is good.
But now not everyone wants to do that.
You need to be able to progress the game well without having to do much trade.
But I do think that like, you know, look, it's definitely going to be the case that if you're playing in a trade league, you're going to have the ability to accelerate you very significantly.
And that's that's the case.
And it will continue to be the case.
And yeah, like we are a game that embraces trade.
Yeah, I think the DNA of Path of Exile 1 is very much that like it is a game about economy and trade.
And for some people getting riches, they're main motivator.
100%.
So effectively, yes.
So I mean, that that will absolutely be a factor.
And look, like, I think that the feeling of that will probably end up feeling quite similar to POE1 in that regard.
And I think that's what you know, that's the type of game we're making.
Yeah. Do you think it's that said, though, do you think it is in some ways better for us all a self-found sort of experience?
I mean, I simply do simply because again, as we talked about, we're dropping a lot more currency that we expect you to use on gear as opposed to save to end game for one.
And then by end game, like we don't have Kiraak mods costing, you know, that kind of stuff that all costs chaos.
And you don't have like the meta mods costing divines and all that.
Right. They're all different items.
You know, I want meta mod crafting.
There's a ritual.
I know where to get it as well.
Right.
But you're not just like having to, I'm blocked behind this thing because I need so many divines and I can't get that because I'm solo self-found and farming divines is not exactly, you know, beyond trivial.
So, you know, there's a number of ways there where I'd say it is honestly a much better solo self-found experience.
But, you know, each to their own, that to be seen and, you know.
And there'll be a separate solo self-found mode, presumably, even potentially beta launch or in the future?
So that is our intention to have hardcore and solo self-found.
I love both of them.
Cool.
I wouldn't play hardcore for your first round, honestly, because you're likely to die.
Once you learn the boss mechanics, it should be fine.
But someone's gonna.
First time, you know, it's going to be tricky.
Couch co-op hardcore and you get to see a friend die right next to you.
That's the true dream.
Actually, hang on a minute.
In couch co-op hardcore, do we still lock the camera so you can't walk away from your friend?
No, we put you back to solo.
You put you back to solo.
Okay, great.
That's good to know.
It's like you have a morning period of about 30 seconds.
Right, right, right.
But you just say, all right, you can go home now.
What do you do?
Yeah, that is a devastating moment.
So I did lose my place there.
Yeah, I think we mentioned co-op support and everything.
We'll scroll down and take some of the additional questions here.
Excellent.
Thanks.
So will there be a penalty for individual party member dying when grouping up for bosses on that note?
It seems weird that the boss straight up resets when playing solo, but when playing in a group, nothing happens if a party member dies.
Tell us about the rules.
I know you've changed them recently.
Yeah, so bosses are obviously harder for having more people.
Less crowd controls, things like obviously more life.
And I'm not saying double life, more than double life.
It does get more than twice as hard or more than end players as hard.
So yes, you could argue, okay, we have reviving as an advantage.
Well, yes, it does.
It does take time to revive.
And if your friend dies early and you're unable to revive them because you're constantly being interrupted, well, you're not having a fun time.
You get a big stun or something.
Another change that we made recently is, of course, for each revived between each set of checkpoints, every time you have to revive them, the revive takes longer.
Subsequent times.
So that's important because it just means that if you're like you can't revive spam anymore because it's longer and longer each time.
But then when you go to a checkpoint that resets, so like you're back to normal.
In game maps, you cannot revive each other.
Death is a consequence.
Yeah.
I was going to ask actually about like in game maps and what is the rule for dying in a game map?
Is it one portal deal now, not six portals?
Well, you still have six portals so you have your party members, but death.
And you can leave and come back.
You can take items out, but a death will end that map for you.
Yeah.
And to remind people, if you log out or server crashes or something like that's going to happen, then the game pauses.
So when you log when you boot the game back up and log back in, you'll be still in your map.
And also, we've also now have it so that if you just order for the game at a random time, you'll actually even if you come back like the next day.
Because for example, you might have rage quit.
You will appear back at the checkpoint you were at.
So if you are like fighting a boss, you die a bunch of times, you're like, oh crap, order for you come back.
You're going to be right there at the boss checkpoint.
That part is campaign specific because there are no checkpoints in maps.
Yeah, non maps. But for the campaign though, that honestly has helped a lot.
There were so many. I think it really did cause new players to have problems in PRB1 where they felt like they just lost track of where the hell they even were when they came back after a session.
They might have not got waypoints at certain times or things like that.
You now kind of have a situation where you log back in and you're like, oh, I forgot like three waypoints in a row.
Now I'm like freaking miles away from where I was, which I think happened to new players fairly frequently.
I'm glad in a world where everyone's becoming a souls like that you guys didn't do the running back to the boss.
Right, right, right.
And you just kind of jump back in.
Yeah, yeah.
And have another crack.
So yeah, so effectively like that, that's nice to just have the same checkpoints to your character, which I think is a nice one.
Were there any other mechanics around there reviving?
Well, obviously in hardcore you did, you did.
That's the drill.
So your maps almost embraces a kind of semi hardcore mentality there where there is actual cost.
Like we went through so many iterations here where it's like, OK, like the moment that you have to spend something of economic value to do the attempt, hence a map item.
And especially if it's got breaches and all this content that's coming from precursor tablets, all of this stuff is worth stuff.
So you all of a sudden have heaps of stuff on the line and then you don't want to be in a position where you're like, no, I need to bring in some people to do this because I'm not going to risk that value.
So that's why we just were like in maps, no reviving.
It's just like, yeah, sure.
You still can always bring in any context someone way more powerful than you to carry things, right?
That's the benefit of multiplayer.
But feeling like you have to do this thing because then they can just keep reviving you so you can get all the rewards.
We're trying to get away from all of that.
Otherwise you get this weird thing where like you're often always too scared to do the thing.
Now, now you're scared, but everyone's scared and it's fine and you don't feel like you're like, OK, you have to go on with a sense of confidence to like I can definitely do this thing.
And so it's just a little bit less fear when it comes to all of a sudden doing that.
That's much better in the context of the fact that you can pause the game if your cat's on fire or if the server crashes or something that you just paused and you can jump back in as well.
You're failing because of your own faults.
Now it's worth noting in multiplayer, we do have a thing, of course, with respawn at checkpoints as an option.
So if a player dies and you don't want to like you don't want to die, you don't want to finish the fight out, you can both choose to respawn at checkpoint and then it will just create a new instance.
You don't have to die to do it and you don't have to log out and do any shenanigans like that.
You can just press escape, hit respawn at checkpoint.
It will ask other players to confirm and then it moves you all to the new area.
Cool. Excellent. I don't want to go super on it because we've definitely talked about it before, but click to move versus WSD has definitely been asked about a bit.
So there's been plenty of reports about WSD being amazing.
Personally, I've been using it a ton and really enjoying it.
I know a lot of you've said a lot of people around the office have like given it a try and adapted to that.
But it has raised the point for people that feel like they're still very much against that for whatever reason, or maybe that they literally only have one hand and want to use click to move still.
How does it stack up? How does click to move still stack up now?
I think honestly it's fine. It's not been a problem.
There was a time where every time I'd go to sit down at a developer's computer, it'd be in WSD and just because it's a little bit easier to move around again or whatever.
But lately I'd say now it's back to almost every designer's computer I sit back down at to go play there back and click to move.
Interesting. It's gone full tilt the other way.
But even watching Octavian play on click to move, he's a hundred percent click to move curious. He's very proficient with that.
That'll be reassuring for I think some of the people that are worried about being forced into WSD, even though it is obviously playing so well by all accounts.
That's very good then.
And Octavian is often doing the demonstrations for your live things too.
You'll be able to see that even.
I have to force them to play WSD sometimes because I'm like, oh, I think the Mercenary looks so much better with WSD just visually.
So, you know, I tell them to.
It does feel very good on the Mercenary.
Yeah.
They're kind of like stalking through, especially with that kind of like preparational tactical play style.
Yeah, that's good.
Loving it so far.
We did already talk about the skin transfers.
Can we scroll down to any additional questions that we have?
I feel like we have a lot of questions.
I mean, it's a while.
We're getting creep in at this point.
Exactly.
We've been going.
We've been rolling.
Yeah.
People asking if there's going to be anything like challenges or challenge rewards in the early access.
Not at first, no.
We will do it later though.
Did I ask about races, events and private leagues?
I think not initially, but we will do it later for sure.
I think the I'm not sure what happened because I think I think the early access is going to be a bit of a challenge.
I think the I'm not sure what happened because I think I think the issue was that the private league interface was like on the P.O.E.
one site and we had to do some work and something like that.
It wouldn't be far away though.
It won't take that long before we get to it.
I can't exactly remember either.
But yeah, it wouldn't be private leagues in particular.
It wouldn't be far away.
Yeah.
So I mean, we'll have them just not like right initially, potentially.
And I think I did miss this actually.
So cluster jewels are a thing or not a thing.
Are they they've been kind of replaced by those?
Yeah, we replaced them with that almost like rollable timeless jewel kind of thing.
Yeah, that's at least for now.
There's like so much passive tree there and the jewels accomplished the kind of off build thing anyway.
Hardly need to add the extra passive trees on your passive trees.
Yes.
We don't have to launch.
We made the passive tree implicitly bigger.
So because the jewels are in the tree.
Thanks again.
I talk about like year three features.
That's that's around a year three to year five feature as well.
Yeah, we got another decade of what we had with Path of Exile one to look forward to for Path of Exile two, hopefully, before we start worrying about Path of Exile three, maybe.
Geez.
You go just just start thinking, just start thinking about that.
Give us a little while.
We are.
So I guess to just finish us off for today then.
Do you guys have a recommendation or what is the best class to play in the beta?
I mean, that's a very hard one.
Honestly, like.
So many choices now.
There are.
So let me.
Well, OK.
If we're going by the numbers.
Oh yeah.
If we go by player satisfaction reports on per class, we break it down from the beta.
This is good technical information here.
Then that means the monk is very interesting because the monk is the class that dies the most often.
It's also the class that when people play it, they have the highest satisfaction level by a very, very tiny margin compared to the others.
That's fascinating.
I mean, it is like glass cannon, you know, like it's very fast, but you have to you have to retreat and move in and out.
I fell in love with the monk playing it.
It looks like it's got a little better.
Yeah, yeah, that's interesting.
But I think if you're a new player, then the mercenary, if you're like used to shooters and stuff, I think playing the mercenary could be a good one.
Like I really love that class.
I know I've been loving the mercenary.
But to me, it feels like you need to really be considering each engagement a lot more.
It's a bit more tactical.
I like it.
I really like that.
Honestly, like I mean, I go through favorite classes all the time whenever I change to play a different class that becomes my favorite.
So, you know, whatever I'm playing tends to be the thing.
So yeah, right now I'm doing a mercenary playthrough.
So that's probably why I'm into that.
But yeah, I'm not sure if you've got a similar.
You're talking about the numbers as well.
It was interesting that monk and then warrior had the highest satisfaction.
Warrior is next, by the way, technically, if you're looking for.
That's pretty good.
That's two melee classes.
Exactly.
That's a win.
Yeah, that's something going on.
I mean, they were dying a lot more at the time.
It's such a change from like, especially early Pufferpigs I won.
Like it's got a little better in one day.
But still, I mean, I just have a light real desire to freeze time.
So I just want to go.
I don't know what skills I'll play.
I feel like she's not getting enough.
I don't know what skills I'll play, but I definitely just want to be able to freeze time.
So I just feel so.
All right. So you could be playing.
You could be playing crossbow building.
Yeah, I might be a crossbow time freezer.
I don't know.
We'll see what's going on.
Yeah, all right.
I noted I liked that I'd noted that our mercenaries were very different as well.
I was playing full Grenada.
You were.
I was doing the freeze, the freeze, freeze shotgun.
Yeah, very cool.
Yeah.
Some sort of monk trigger build, obviously, is always just going to be fun to.
So many of those like stacking effects, the wind and the ice coming off it.
And the sentencies showed some more as well.
Just see how far they can be pushed and how many spells can I get to.
Trigger per second.
Yeah, like doesn't seem good for that.
All righty.
Well, thank you very much for your time.
Both of you for I don't even know how long that was a mammoth session.
Coming up to one o'clock here.
So, you know, still wants to talk about.
I think we just need some time to digest for sure.
So thankfully we didn't have everyone saying patch notes when this time.
So good.
So that's a conversation.
There's no pressure on this.
Wrap it up.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
So, you know, that's good.
Fantastic.
All right.
Thank you very much for watching everybody.
I hope you enjoyed the Q&A.
That was a good day.
They want patch notes now.
It's not a patch.
Exactly.
Where's the launch notes?
Yeah.
All right.
And thank you very much.
Thanks, Heaps.
Appreciate it.
It's been an epic journey.
It's kind of surreal.
And it's only the start of another journey, really.
So that's it.
Yeah.
Can't wait to play.
It's cool.
I'm going to play more now, but yeah.
True.
Sorry.
I got to go fix bosses going up elevators.
Yeah.
I'm just pre-bug testing.
All right.
I assume we've faded out and cut.
Hopefully.
You never know.
Bye.